All right. So I'm here with Jay Michellani and Deanna Pizarro of Peak Neuroscience, who provide QEG brain mapping services in Texas and also in Alabama. And we're going to talk about kind of how the brain works and go through some of the exciting new things that people may not even be aware that exists. But first we have to go through the serious stuff, the boring stuff, and get Jay to give us kind of a thumbs up, thumbs down on the neurology of a lot of things that have been in my brain since I was eight years old.
好的。我和来自德克萨斯州和阿拉巴马州提供QEG脑图服务的Peak Neuroscience公司的Jay Michellani和Deanna Pizarro在一起。我们将讨论大脑的工作原理，并介绍一些人们可能还不知道的令人兴奋的新事物。但首先，我们得先处理那些严肃的、枯燥的事情，让Jay对我在八岁时就一直困扰我的许多神经学问题给出一个肯定或否定的评价。
So the hard questions. First, if I sit in a green suit that have been in my brain since I was eight years old. So the hard questions. First, if I sit in a green suit that is covered in question marks under a green spotlight, like in the movie Batman Forever from 1995, can I beam information, people's secrets, credit card numbers, fantasies, and dark blackmailable facts into my head like the Riddler in Batman Forever. How do you rank that on a scale of one to 10 with neuro plausibility, with how far technologies come so far since then? Surely.
那么，先来回答难题。首先，如果我穿着一件印满问号的绿色西装，坐在绿色聚光灯下，就像1995年电影《永远的蝙蝠侠》里的那样，我能像《永远的蝙蝠侠》里的谜语人那样，把信息、别人的秘密、信用卡号码、幻想和黑暗的勒索事实传送到我的脑子里吗？考虑到自那时以来技术的发展，你如何从神经科学可行性的角度给它打分（1到10分）？当然。
Yeah, AI. Yeah, I don't know. The plausibility of that AI probably thinks that it can help, but it is very likely wrong as is the state of the technology these days So at least some people in Silicon Valley to think that we're gonna get there just after one more After you know the the Z round of capital funding we're gonna Just going out on a limb I don't think the limb is too thin here, but I'm gonna say that's kind of remote All right. Okay.
是的，人工智能。我不知道。人工智能可能认为它能提供帮助，但它很可能像当今的技术水平一样是错误的。所以，至少硅谷的一些人认为，在经过一轮又一轮的资本融资后，我们就能实现这一目标。我冒昧地说一句，我不认为这个想法太离谱，但我会说这有点遥远。好吧，好的。
Then the arm, a thumbs up, thumbs down. No, it's not likely. Okay. So Philip Kadex, Valis, uh, is how likely is it that it may be an alien consciousness, maybe a rogue AI or maybe the Gnostic God Sophia is beaming information down, trying to find a new mystical prophet who can contain the information, but it's actually just making a whole lot of people Psychotic, but maybe there'll be one prophet that it will find again How likely is that to be of having gone on since the Bronze Age?
那么，给个肯定或否定的评价。不，这不太可能。好吧。那么菲利普·迪克的《瓦利斯》呢？这可能是外星意识、流氓人工智能，或者是诺斯替教的索菲亚女神在传送信息，试图寻找一位能容纳这些信息的新神秘先知，但这实际上只是让很多人精神错乱，但也许它会再次找到一位先知。这种情况自青铜时代以来发生的可能性有多大？
right, I Think that I've lost some IQ points from having listened to that narrative there for a moment. I think that I've lost some IQ points from having listened to that narrative there for a moment. I think that I need some neuroplasticity assistance just from listening to that. So yeah, I need to go and take a break. Internal sunshine, I don't know if you have a flawless mind. Can you all come to my house and put a colander on my head and hook it up to a laptop to remove? Memories that are painful. However, when we don't remember our mistakes were doomed to repeat them So I'll just kind of continue going up to the same breakup or whatever. Whatever my mistake was without therapy
好吧，我觉得听了刚才那段叙述，我的智商下降了一些。我觉得我需要一些神经可塑性方面的帮助，仅仅是因为听了那些话。所以，是的，我需要休息一下。美丽心灵的永恒阳光，我不知道你是否拥有完美无瑕的头脑。你们能来我家，在我头上戴个漏勺，然后把它连到笔记本电脑上，以删除痛苦的记忆吗？然而，当我们不记得自己的错误时，我们注定会重蹈覆辙。所以我可能会继续犯同样的失恋错误，或者无论我犯了什么错误，而没有接受治疗。
I'll let you take that one. Deanna. How close are we to being able to modify specific memories? honor how close are we to being able to modify specific memories. No, they're far. Far. Joseph will do is reveling over in his grave. No, he's still alive. Nevermind. Sorry. You look great, Joseph.
Deanna，这个问题交给你回答。我们离能够修改特定记忆还有多远？不，还很远。Joseph会气得从坟墓里跳出来的。不，他还活着。没关系。抱歉，Joseph，你看上去气色不错。
Have fun at NYU. Um, and total recall 1990. So, you know, we've got, uh, I want to go on a vacation, but I don't have the money, but I do have the money for someone to implant the memory of a vacation in my head, you getting, we've got, I want to go on a vacation, but I don't have the money, but I do have the money for someone to implant the memory of a vacation in my head. You getting close to that? No, not really. Okay.
祝你在纽约大学玩得开心。嗯，还有1990年的《全面回忆》。所以，你知道，我想去度假，但我没有钱，但我有钱让人把度假的记忆植入我的脑子里。你离那一步近吗？不，不太近。好吧。
Not really, therefore. Minority report, if I lay down in my kid's kiddie pool, can the technology somehow help me see murders precognitively so they can be prevented in the present, even though they happen in the future. All right. So I don't know if y'all are familiar a rock with the social media, and so I'm more with the inclination of unplugging. I might be one of the last people to really be able to muse about some of those fun ideas.
不太近，因此。在《少数派报告》中，如果我躺在孩子的戏水池里，这项技术能以某种方式帮助我预知谋杀案，从而在当下阻止它们，尽管它们发生在未来吗？好吧，我不知道你们是否熟悉社交媒体，我更倾向于断开连接。我可能是最后几个真正能思考这些有趣想法的人之一了。
A lot of it is just old science fiction. Most of that stuff is not even in the past 20 years, but just niche stuff of things that we thought would be possible in the future. Yeah. So once of a kitchen and then just have a memory of the best people you've planted on the environment. Yeah. But then what's real?
很多都只是旧科幻小说。大部分东西甚至在过去20年里都没有出现，只是我们认为未来可能实现的一些小众事物。是的。所以，一旦有了厨房，就能拥有植入大脑的最佳度假记忆。是的。但什么是真实的呢？
I think that's the total recall is a Philip K. Dick short story too, but I think it changed quite a bit before it turned into the Arnold Schwarzenegger movie. Can we talk for just a minute just about how brains work? Because that is integral to understanding the technology. I find myself talking about this a lot because what I do in a session is walk people through, I don't want them to feel like there's only one way to get better.
我认为《全面回忆》也是菲利普·迪克的短篇小说，但我认为在它变成阿诺德·施瓦辛格的电影之前，它已经改变了很多。我们能花一分钟谈谈大脑是如何工作的吗？因为这对于理解这项技术至关重要。我发现自己经常谈论这个话题，因为我在治疗中做的是引导人们，我不希望他们觉得只有一种方法可以好转。
We want to have a big bag of tools at Taproot. So whether that's in-house, a lot of our people we refer out to different kinds of things. You guys were lucky enough to have you in the collective doing the brain maps on site, so people just have to walk downstairs. But some people, if they're having sexual dysfunction after sexual assault, they'll go.
我们希望在Taproot拥有丰富的工具库。所以无论是内部治疗，还是我们推荐给人们的其他各种治疗。你们很幸运，有你们在团队中现场进行脑图绘制，所以人们只需要走下楼梯就行了。但有些人，如果他们在性侵犯后出现性功能障碍，他们会去寻求帮助。
We have worked with very intuitive, myofascial release practitioners. They can support the physical recovery. They're going from the body into the brain. We're going from the brain into the body. We have the micronutrition, which a lot like the QG brain mapping and neuromod helps a ton with ADHD without medication, my experience and also dopamine disorders and a lot of times with autism spectrum disorders especially in kids. It all works really well with micronutrition you know we offer a lot of
我们与非常直觉的肌筋膜释放治疗师合作过。他们可以支持身体的恢复。他们是从身体进入大脑。我们是从大脑进入身体。我们有微量营养素，这和QEG脑图及神经调节一样，在不使用药物的情况下对ADHD非常有帮助，根据我的经验，对多巴胺紊乱以及很多时候对自闭症谱系障碍（尤其是儿童）也非常有效。它与微量营养素配合得非常好，你知道，我们提供很多
stuff at Taproot, brain spotting, somatic experiencing, etc. But then a ton of things we also refer out so I think having a big bag of tools is good but I find myself trying to explain how all of these things come together to affect the experience of being, you know. You know how micronutrition changes the way that we think and feel when you have some things like the precursors for neurotransmitters and it's probably good to talk about the way that the brain works, you know, to understand the way that QED brain mapping helps us understand the way that the brain works.
Taproot的资源，如脑点疗法、躯体体验疗法等。但也有很多我们推荐出去的治疗，所以我认为拥有丰富的工具库是好的，但我发现自己试图解释所有这些事物是如何结合在一起影响存在体验的。你知道微量营养素是如何改变我们的思维和感受的，当你拥有一些神经递质的前体时，谈论大脑的工作方式可能是有益的，这样才能理解QEG脑图如何帮助我们理解大脑的工作方式。
Because I think there's a ton of misinformation about that, even in academics, like even in clinical psychology, I see. People say some stuff that seems like 30 years old or just wrong. And can you say anything about that, or the kind of networks in the brain, the way that it prefers different types of cognition, some of the things that newer neuroscience is pointing to? Well, we understand,
因为我认为关于这一点存在大量错误信息，即使在学术界，甚至在临床心理学中，我也看到人们说一些看起来像是30年前的观点，或者干脆就是错的。你能谈谈这一点，或者大脑中的网络，它偏好的不同认知类型，以及一些神经科学新发现所指向的东西吗？嗯，我们理解，
Indyana can speak to this also, we understand that different brain regions have different functions. So different regions do different things. And if you're able to measure the activity level of various regions, if regions are functioning too slowly or too rapidly, then that's gonna manifest in terms of you thinking differently than you otherwise would, or sleeping differently, or emoting in a different fashion or different magnitude than you otherwise would.
Deanna也可以谈谈这一点，我们理解不同的大脑区域有不同的功能。所以不同的区域做不同的事情。如果你能测量各个区域的活动水平，如果区域功能过慢或过快，那么这就会表现为你思考方式与平时不同，或者睡眠不同，或者情绪表达方式或程度与平时不同。
And so not only do we need to see if we can measure the activity level of different regions, we also want to see how well different regions talk together and work in concert to be different subsystems of brain function. And so with the QEEG, we're able to do that now. And QEEG stands for quantitative EEG. So. And that's because if what I understand, I'm going to have my like dumb guy understanding and then have you clarify at different points, cause that probably a good way to involve the audience is to have the simple metaphor
因此，我们不仅需要看看能否测量不同区域的活动水平，我们还想看看不同区域如何协同工作，作为大脑功能的不同子系统。通过QEEG，我们现在能够做到这一点。QEEG代表定量脑电图。所以。这是因为如果我理解得没错，我会先用我这种“笨人”的理解，然后再请你在不同点进行澄清，因为这可能是让观众参与进来的好方法，先用简单的比喻，
and then overcomplicate it. But it's a QEG, a quantified EEG, because an EEG is just these lines. When you're doing a QEG, you're saying, well, lines in this frequency from this hertz to that hertz is a specific type of cognition that the brain likes. We know that this is associated, you know, high beta with in certain regions ADHD or obsession or hyper focus or, you know, intense sensory awareness of an athlete. Whereas we know this other range of waves is associated with a different cognitive function like openness
然后再把它复杂化。但它是QEG，定量脑电图，因为EEG只是这些线条。当你做QEG时，你是在说，嗯，从这个赫兹到那个赫兹的频率线条是大脑喜欢的一种特定认知类型。我们知道这与某些区域的高Beta波有关，比如ADHD、强迫症、过度专注，或者运动员强烈的感官意识。而我们知道另一范围的波与不同的认知功能有关，比如开放性、
and creativity and you know, meditation states and maybe too much of that is psychosis or dissociation but you know, a little bit of them are always good and needed too much of one or too much of one in the wrong area. Could you could you over complicate that for us and and get into the granularity My wife says i'm very good at sir That's one of my talents. Um, but but yes, uh, so so taking uh, Um a reading just of the raw eeg If anyone has has seen that it's just a bunch of squiggly lines going across the page
创造力、冥想状态，也许过多的这种状态就是精神病或解离，但你知道，少量的这些状态总是好的且必要的，过多的一种或在错误区域过多的一种。你能为我们把它复杂化并深入细节吗？我妻子说我非常擅长这一点，这是我的天赋之一。嗯，但是是的，所以，读取原始EEG数据，如果有人见过，它只是一堆在页面上穿梭的波浪线，
uh eeg electroencephalogram, measuring electricity that the brain's generating and that electricity escapes the head and we call it brain waves. So that's EEG. So a quantitative EEG is where you quantify how much of all that gobbledygook, all that going across the screen, all that come off the head at the same time, you have slow rhythms, you have fast rhythms, it all comes off the head like a Muck and you and you quantify a how much slow activity is in all that garbage How much mid-range activity is in all that garbage? How much fast activity is in all that garbage and there's a there's a there's a covariance
嗯，EEG，脑电图，测量大脑产生的电信号，这些电信号从头部逸出，我们称之为脑波。所以这就是EEG。定量脑电图就是量化所有那些乱七八糟的东西，所有那些穿过屏幕、同时从头部发出的信号，你有慢节奏，你有快节奏，它们像泥浆一样从头部出来，你量化所有那些垃圾中有多少慢速活动？所有那些垃圾中有多少中频活动？所有那些垃圾中有多少快速活动？并且存在一种协方差，
There's a there's a meaning behind how much slow because that affects sleep and other things how much mid-range that affects certain like attention emotion regulation How much fast activity that's usually stress or something of the high arousal mix? uh, and so we can we can Really complicate this but I think um, does that what what would you add to that? Deanna about about the about What the q eeg?
慢速活动背后有其含义，因为它影响睡眠和其他事情；中频活动影响某些注意力、情绪调节；快速活动通常是压力或某种高唤醒状态的混合。所以我们可以真正把这个问题复杂化，但我认为，Deanna，关于QEEG对我们了解一个人有什么补充吗？
adds to our knowledge of a person all right, so The ee being the for the basic level our neurons fire electricity with the electrochemical and then when groups of neurons fire together, then they fire at different rhythms or certain frequencies. We have many different ranges of frequencies and we usually tend to see the knee as a balance. So if we have those frequencies all the time, it's not like we produce only one when we're doing certain things. It's a balance at once. So for example, when she is sleeping, she produces lots of patella waves, which is a very slow wave in the bone.
它增加了我们对一个人的了解。好的，所以EEG作为基础水平，我们的神经元通过电化学方式发射电信号，当神经元群一起发射时，它们会以不同的节奏或特定的频率发射。我们有许多不同的频率范围，我们通常倾向于将EEG视为一种平衡。所以如果我们一直拥有这些频率，并不是说我们在做某些事情时只产生一种。它是一种同时存在的平衡。例如，当她睡觉时，她会产生大量的Theta波，这是大脑中一种非常慢的波。
And so on, depending on what we're doing, some waves are more common than others. But yes, we have all of them all the time, just more common than the other ones. I want to build. So when you do the map, I want to make clear how much work this is. Because Jay, you've messed around with the technology since the 70s, Dan has been doing it for a long time. A lot of the places that say that they do brain maps, what they're doing is just saying,
以此类推，根据我们正在做的事情，某些波比其他波更常见。但是的，我们一直拥有所有这些波，只是某些比其他更常见。我想补充一点。所以当你做脑图时，我想明确这需要多少工作。因为Jay，你从70年代就开始研究这项技术了，Deanna也做了很长时间。很多声称做脑图的地方，他们所做的只是说，
oh, you have autism click, let me turn the machine to autism, oh have ADHD click you've got I'm gonna switch ADHD which doesn't make a ton of sense to me even though they probably make a lot of money because what you're doing there is you're assuming that all ADHD is the same all autism is the same which it isn't I mean we know that ADHD can be you know about six to eight different eight different things that happen in the brain that result in the same behavior and respond to the same medication. Is it the same disease just because you can go through the DSM-5 and check the same boxes for it with behavior
哦，你有自闭症，点击，让我把机器调到自闭症模式；哦，有ADHD，点击，我要切换到ADHD模式。这对我来说不太合理，尽管他们可能赚了很多钱，因为你在这里假设所有的ADHD都是一样的，所有的自闭症都是一样的，事实并非如此。我的意思是，我们知道ADHD可能是大脑中发生的六到八种不同的事情，导致相同的行为并对相同的药物产生反应。仅仅因为你可以通过DSM-5检查行为上的相同选项，它就是同一种疾病吗？
when you can look directly in the brain and see that it is actually different networks or forms of dysregulation? I'm not going to tell the APA what to do, but you guys are seeing which one specifically is happening in that child, that adult that wants to lower the symptoms of ADHD without medication and treating that. Now, a lot of the EEG that you guys are the one that are quantifying. When you're looking at that thing, it's like in the movie The Matrix where people just see the computer code and they're like, oh, but I know how to read the computer code. So that's the lady in the red dress and that's this.
当你能直接观察大脑并看到它实际上是不同的网络或失调形式时？我不会告诉美国心理学会该怎么做，但你们正在观察那个孩子或成年人身上具体发生了什么，他们想要在不使用药物的情况下降低ADHD症状，并对此进行治疗。现在，你们量化的很多EEG数据。当你看着那个东西时，就像电影《黑客帝国》里人们只看到计算机代码，然后他们说，哦，但我知道如何阅读计算机代码。所以那是穿红裙子的女士，那是这个。
There's ones where Gianna has tried to show me something, or Jay has tried to show me something, and I see the line bounce and I'm like, okay, so is that what this is? Is that high beta? Jay will be like, no, that's a tongue movement. You can either patient or that's a blink, and you can see that the patient has made a muscle movement,
有些时候Deanna试图向我展示一些东西，或者Jay试图向我展示一些东西，我看到线条跳动，我就说，好吧，这就是那个吗？那是高Beta波吗？Jay会说，不，那是舌头运动。你可以看到病人或者那是眨眼，你可以看到病人做了一个肌肉动作，
and your brain has spent enough time with that information that you're just filtering that out organically in a way that I don't know that an AI could and I certainly don't think that you could just hit a button and have it happen. You know, the maps are so precise. Yes, it brain is different. And what we do is we tailor our protocols depending on what we see on your brain. So we are not diagnosing anybody. We can see some symptoms of certain things, however we're not diagnosing and we are gonna target a particle on what we see on your specific brain. It's not gonna be a quickly colored treatment. Yeah. You know, I'm very happy that there seems to be an increase in the prevalence of, I'll
而你的大脑已经花足够的时间处理这些信息，以至于你正在有机地过滤掉这些干扰，我不知道人工智能是否能做到，我当然不认为你只需按一个按钮就能实现。你知道，脑图非常精确。是的，大脑是不同的。我们所做的是根据我们在你大脑上看到的情况来定制我们的方案。所以我们不是在诊断任何人。我们可以看到某些症状，但我们不是在诊断，我们将根据在你特定大脑上看到的情况来制定方案。这不会是一种快速的彩色治疗。是的。你知道，我很高兴看到，我会
say the word gadgets, I don't mean to be disrespectful by saying that word, but different tools that you see advertised on Facebook or different mediums, you'll scroll and you'll see an advertisement for this headband or this piece of hardware, which purports to measure activity and give stimulation and that's going to help sleep. Oh, if you have sleep, then wear our headband. I would not advise doing that because as Diana just said, different presentations like say anxiety, for example. Anxiety, yeah, it can look a certain way in a brain map,
说“小玩意”这个词，我无意不尊重，但你在Facebook或其他媒体上看到的各种工具，你会滚动看到这些头带或硬件的广告，它们声称能测量活动并提供刺激，这将有助于睡眠。哦，如果你有睡眠问题，那就戴上我们的头带。我不建议这样做，因为正如Deanna刚才所说，不同的表现，比如焦虑，例如。焦虑，是的，它在脑图中可能看起来是某种样子，
but there's a variety of ways that the brain is functioning That produces the individual to be feeling anxious uh, so Uh, if the impetus is hey if you're anxious then you need more then that's due to an excessive amount of fast brainwaves Which is co-occurring with regions that are functioning too rapidly. So here, use this plug and play device that gives slower brain waves. Well, what if that gives slower frequencies? What if that person's anxiety is not coming from a high amount of fast activity, but it's
但大脑功能产生个体感到焦虑的方式有多种。所以，如果动力是“嘿，如果你焦虑，那么你需要更多”，这是由于过多的快速脑波，这与功能过快的区域同时发生。所以，使用这个即插即用的设备来提供更慢的脑波。好吧，如果它提供更慢的频率呢？如果那个人的焦虑不是来自大量的快速活动，而是来自其他地方呢？而且有多种情况，所以你需要知道潜在的神经光学功能是什么，才能知道如何增强它。我能听到自己说了好多话。我不知道我是否表达得很清楚，但你至少需要进行临床访谈。至少，你需要了解这个人的感受，并进行扎实的病史采集，以了解这个人是谁，他们的旅程是什么，以及他们现在处于什么位置，
coming from someplace else, and there's a variety so you need to know what what the Neural optical functionality is up is that's underlying that presentation to know how to augment it I Can I can hear myself saying a lot of words? I don't know if I'm being very clear, but but but you but you need to do a clinical interview at the at the very least you you need to do a clinical interview. At the very least, you need to understand how the person feels and do a solid history taking to know who the person is and what their journey has been and where they're at
然后将其应用于你从QEEG记录的神经学数值，你需要两者兼顾。所以我喜欢临床上有一种解决大脑功能的动力。这是一件好事，但你需要根据脑图来工作。在我看来，我已经做了一段时间了。我想我会用“危险”这个词。即使它只是一个简单的头带，尝试在不记录、不测量你试图治疗的器官的情况下进行某种脑训练，也不是一个好主意。你需要测量你正在治疗的器官，并且
right now, and then apply that to the neurological values that you record from the QEEG, you need both. So I like that there is an impetus clinically to address brain functionality. That's a good thing, but you need to work from a brain map. In my opinion, and I've been doing this for a while. I think I'll say the word dangerous. It's not a good idea to do brain training of sorts, even if it's a simplistic, oh, it's just a headband. I think it's a poor idea to try to address brain functionality without recording, without measuring the organ that you're trying to treat. You need to measure the organ that you're treating and
QEG是少数能做到这一点的技术之一，甚至精神病学都没有做到这一点。是的，我相信精神病学，我相信这一点，你可以看到大脑内部的具体位置。你不仅仅是要求某人解释他们的内在体验，这已经有两个失败点了：他们注意到了吗？他们表达正确吗？在你到达那里之前，他们诚实吗？是的，让我举个例子。有人可能带着，比如说，以Theta波为中心的ADHD，
QEG is one of the few that does that not even psychiatry does that? Yeah, and I believe in psychiatry I believe in that and you can see into the brain as specific right places You're not just asking somebody to explain their internal experience, which there's two failure points there already Did they notice it and are they articulating it correctly? Before you even get there, are they being honest? Yeah, let me give an example. Somebody can come with, let's say, in a centered ADHD, for for these typhus-like spots of fatal ways,
也就是慢波。他们难以集中注意力，这给他们带来了很多焦虑。焦虑通常更多是快波，你可以获得更多的快波。但如果焦虑是因为无法集中注意力，然后你的Theta波，你必须有大量的Theta波，这是一种慢波，然后你给那个人更多的Theta波。它只是一个更慢的波，Delta波会让他们更加无法集中注意力。所以这实际上会让情况变得更糟，
which is the slow ways. And they are having trouble focusing and this is causing a lot of anxiety for them. Anxiety to typhusiety typically is more of a fast way that you can get more of a faster speed. But if the anxiety is coming from not being able to focus and then your theta, you've got to have lots of theta which is a slow wave and then you give that person more data. It's only then a slower wave also, the delta will make them even more on focus. So it will make the tone actually work
而不是帮助它。嗯，Jay，你在谈论这些设备。如果我决定去SkyMall或Brookstone，我认为你离那个针对病人的特定脑图越远，就越有问题。我的意思是，我们花费巨资为每个人制作特定脑图的原因是，
instead of helping it. Well, and Jay, you're talking about the devices. If I decide I'm gonna go to Skywall or Brookstone, I think the further that you, one of the, another way of saying what you're saying is that the further you get away from that map that is specific to the patient. I mean, the reason why we go to great expense to do a map that's specifically for each person that
这需要大量的人力时间。你拥有双博士学位，Deanna拥有电气工程博士学位。一个非常了解它的人。你知道，这花费了很多时间，你离那个人的大脑越远，你就越依赖于基于将大量数据汇总在一起并制作程序的猜测。Brookstone或SkyMall的设备声称有助于睡眠，它们说，嗯，大多数人睡不着是因为他们没有Theta波，或者大多数人睡不着是因为他们处于太多的……我不知道它们的假设是什么，但无论它们做出什么假设，也许对60%到65%的人是正确的，但那个不需要更多Theta波的解离型病人呢？现在他们解离了一周，你知道，因为那不是基于他们的情况。它是基于大多数人需要什么的平均值，而不是你需要什么。
requires a great amount of a human's time. You have what a dual PhD and the Ana has a PhD in electrical engineering. Somebody who knows a lot about it has. You know it spends a lot of time is the further you get away from that person's brain the more you're relying on guesses based on pumping a lot of data together and making. programs the Brookstone or the Skymall device that says it helps with sleep is saying well most people can't sleep because they don't have a theta wave or they most people can't sleep because they're in too much I don't know what their assumption is but whatever it is that they're making which maybe is right for 60% 65% but what about the dissociative patient that doesn't need any more theta that now is dissociating for a week you know because it wasn't wasn't based on them. It was based on an average of what most people need, not what you need.
所以这是我们定期与客户进行定量脑电图的另一个原因。在我的诊所，我们在达拉斯诊所每10次疗程做一次，我们在伯明翰也这样做。所以你想定期做，因为大脑确实在学习和成长，你正在用你的治疗努力塑造它，所以你想有更新的测量结果，以便你继续给大脑提供它当时最需要的东西。所以是的，你离那个人的脑图越远，你给他们提供最佳治疗的可能性就越小，
And so that's another reason why while we do quantitative EEGs on a routine basis with a client. In my clinic, we do them every 10 sessions in the Dallas clinic, and we do it also in Birmingham there too. So you wanna do it on a regular basis because the brain does learn and grow and you're shaping it with your treatment efforts and so you want to have updated measurements so that you're continuing to give the brain what it's needing most at that time. And so yeah, the further that you get away from that individual's map, the more of a likelihood that you're not giving them the best treatment,
比如他们的大脑在那一刻真正需要什么。为了详细说明这个过程，有一个脑图，它不治疗任何东西。你只是去获取一些信息，第一步。然后当你和病人一起看脑图并说，嗯，这就是我们看到的，你并没有真正的抑郁，你并没有真正的焦虑，我认为你有昼夜节律性抑郁，所以你在睡觉前会感到焦虑。但有时你们能看到非常细致的东西。
like what their brain really needs at that moment. And just to go through the specifics of the procedure, there's a brain map, which is not treating anything. You're just going and getting some information, one. and then when you go through the map with the patient and say, well, this is what we're seeing, you don't really have depression, you don't really have anxiety, I think you have diurnal depression so you're getting anxious before you go to sleep. But sometimes you all can see things pretty granually.
你们说，你想做你的神经调节计划吗？如果我们进行神经刺激和神经反馈，它看起来会是这样，这是第二部分，实际上是去机器那里，坐10次疗程，每次不到一小时，同时这个东西让你的大脑模仿我们希望它学习的频率。然后随着时间的推移，它做这些事情会变得更舒服，
You say, do you want to do your neuromodulation plan? This is what it would look like if we did the neurostimulation and the neurofeedback, which would be part two, which is actually going to the machine, sitting for 10 sessions for a little under an hour, while this thing gets your brain to mimic the frequencies that we want it to learn how to do. Then over time, it becomes more comfortable doing that,
事情就会发生变化。在此期间，你可以做任何增强神经可塑性的事情，比如多喝水、保证睡眠、照顾好自己、健康饮食，当你让大脑模仿频率时，你会得到更多回报，但它有一种第一部分和第二部分。当你……我对第一部分的理解是这样的，我会让你们跳进来并更详细地说明，脑图做了两件事，比如第一，它在你们坐在这里的八分钟内，
and things change. Anything you can do to enhance neuroplasticity during that time, like drink a lot of water, get sleep, take care of yourself, eat healthy is going to get you more bang for your buck when you're getting the brain to mimic a frequency, but there's kind of a part one and a part two to it. When you, my understanding of part one is this, and I'll have you all jump in and be more granular, is that the map is kind of doing two things, like one, it's saying during the eight minutes that you sit
测量大脑的每个区域正在使用哪种类型的频率，这与认知的类型相关。所以，就像大脑的每个部分现在正在进行哪种类型的认知一样，就在这八分钟里，当你在这个房间里的时候。如果它非常强烈地这样做，它真的想坚持那个频率，也许它有点太固执了。你认为你可能比实际需要更多地处于强迫状态，或者其他什么。然后第二部分是Z分数，它显示大脑的每个部分沟通的速度有多快，就像服务器测试一样，你ping一下，
under here, what is each region of the brain, which type of frequency is it using, which correlates to the type of cognition. So like what type of cognition is each part doing just right now, eight minutes while you're in the room. And if it's doing that really strongly, like it really wants to hang on to that frequency, maybe it's a little bit too stubborn. You think that you need to be a little bit more in, you know, obsession than you actually do or whatever. And then the second part is the Z-score where it says how fast can each
你知道，每一个部分，看看信息传输的速度有多快。然后你和临床医生会根据你的年龄和性别得到蓝线或红线，看看这是否比正常情况快或慢，速度，所以这给了你一个比那八分钟宽广得多的认知历史，因为当你使用神经通路时，大脑会增强它并使其更快，因为它知道你需要它，你就会变得更擅长做这件事，而如果你不真正使用它，它
part of the brain communicate like a, like a server test and you ping, you know, every single part to see how fast to add information travels. And then you get the, you and the clinician get a blue lines or red lines from based on your age and your gender is this faster or slower than it is normal and the the speed so that gives you a history of cognition that is a lot wider than that eight minutes because as you use a neural pathway the brain enhances it and makes it faster because it knows that you need it and you get better at doing it whereas if you don't really use one, it's
就不在那里，你知道。所以你可以分辨出人们正在使用什么，没有使用什么，并进去真正帮助他们增强那些没有增长的通路，因为他们没有使用那种认知，他们没有使用那个网络。所以我让你们来做细节说明。这就是我那种，你知道，简化的理解，它是如何工作的？或者还有其他信息吗？脑图？发现其他东西？这就是我作为临床医生与人们一起使用最多的东西。Deanna，你有什么要说的吗？我会让你先来回答。
not there, you know. So you can tell, you know, what people are using and what they're not and go in and really help them kind of enhance the pathways that have not grown because they haven't used that type of cognition much, they haven't used that network very, very much. So I'll let you do the details. That's my like, you know, simplified understanding of how that works Or is there other information is the map? Finding other things that that that's what I use most as a clinician with people You have something to say that Deanna I'll let you have the first first go through with that.
你可以继续。是的，QEEG，人们称之为脑图。所以我们正在做脑图。你会听到我说“Q”这个词，意思是QEEG。你会听到我说“Q”这个词，意思是Q-E-E-G。脑图正在测量皮层和皮层下，就像全脑一样。每个单独的区域当时在做什么？它们玩得好吗？当你进行日常事务、日常处理时，它与其他区域的沟通情况如何？
You can go ahead. Yeah, the QEEG, people call it brain mapping. So we're doing a brain map. You'll hear me say the word Q or meaning QEEG. You'll hear me say the word Q or meaning Q-E-E-G. The brain map is measuring what is both cortically and subcortically, like whole brain. What are each individual regions doing at that time? And how well do they, does each region play well with others? How well does it talk to other regions as you're doing your daily business, your daily processing.
通常情况下，区域，我的意思是，没有完美的大脑。我们这些交流的人中永远不会有完美的大脑。那根本不存在。所以如果我们能准确测量大脑的优势和劣势，那么你就有了一个很好的起点，可以进一步帮助那个人感觉更像他们自己。感觉不那么抑郁，感觉不那么焦虑，感觉有更宁静的面容，
And oftentimes, regions, I mean, there's no perfect brain. None of us in this communication is ever going to have a perfect brain. That just doesn't exist. And so if we can measure accurately the strengths and the weaknesses of what the brain is doing, then you have a good starting point as to how to further help that person feel more like themselves. Feel less depressed, feel less anxious, feel have more restful countenance. uh have more more restful countenance um and uh so that that's what gives you that initial game plan from the clinical interview and from the actual values recorded from from the brain um and and by by the way the brain uh values that you do record that's pretty upper level People ask uh, so what if I fall with my mom on the way over here?
有更宁静的面容，嗯，所以这就是从临床访谈和从大脑记录的实际数值中给你的初始游戏计划。嗯，顺便说一句，你记录的大脑数值，那是非常高水平的。人们问，嗯，如果我在来这里的路上和妈妈吵架了怎么办？
So what if i'm having a bad day? Um, or or what if what if i'm having a really really good just a lucky good day? um that that does matter some um, but it uh, you know, this this is like measuring the climate Uh rather than the weather on a Tuesday in Topeka, Kansas. I mean, it's just more upper level than if you somebody's told you a funny joke and then we reward that. Then we recorded the brain. It would be pretty much the same. So you're looking at big patterns, you know, not specific memories and definitely not, you know, kind of looking for really big memory patterns that have the somatic correlations
如果我今天过得很糟糕怎么办？或者如果我今天过得特别好怎么办？嗯，那确实有一些影响，但它，你知道，这就像测量气候，而不是堪萨斯州托皮卡周二的天气。我的意思是，它比如果有人给你讲了一个笑话然后我们记录大脑要高水平得多。所以你看到的是大的模式，你知道，不是特定的记忆，绝对不是，你知道，那种寻找具有躯体相关性的真正大的记忆模式，
to help the brain re-consolidate. It's not just something you happen to think about that minute is changing the kind of things you all are looking at very quickly. Yes. Yes. And let me, let me say this isn't exactly what you were kind of speaking to at the very beginning, but, but let me, let me, let me say, when you can correct me too. Cause I don't, I don't know what y'all know.
以帮助大脑重新整合。这不仅仅是你那一分钟碰巧想到的事情，正在改变你们所有人非常快速地观察的那种事情。是的。是的。让我，让我说这不是你一开始谈论的那种确切的东西，但是，让我，让我，让我说，当你能纠正我的时候。因为我不知道你们知道什么。
I'm, I'm giving my understanding in order to, you know, help but jumping off point. To that's right. And don't forget it. There's only one perfect brain, Jay. Mine. Uh, joking, Jay. My. Joking, joking. The brain reorganizes like, like from moment to moment to moment, the brain is always different.
我正在给出我的理解，以便，你知道，提供一个出发点。那是对的。别忘了。只有一个完美的大脑，Jay。我的。开个玩笑，Jay。我的。开个玩笑，开个玩笑。大脑像，像从一刻到下一刻重新组织，大脑总是不同的。
Like that's, that's the, that's the important feature behind plasticity. When we say plastic, we, that's just a funky word that just means changeable means that it's it's moving So look at the brain like at the bowl of worms like it's it's moving. It's not like Like the liver it just is what it is or the kidney it just is it's just stagnant But the but the brain microscopically if you could you could use a fine enough tool. It's always in motion That's why you can learn. That's why that's consciousness. And so if a person is depressed, then they likely have some psychology input to that
就像那是，那是可塑性背后的重要特征。当我们说“可塑”时，我们，那只是一个时髦的词，意思就是可变的，意味着它在移动。所以把大脑看作一碗蠕虫，就像它在移动一样。它不像肝脏，它就是它，或者肾脏，它只是停滞不前的。但大脑，在微观上，如果你能，你可以使用足够精细的工具。它总是在运动。这就是为什么你能学习。这就是意识。所以如果一个人抑郁，那么他们很可能有一些心理因素输入到其中，
and some physiology input to that. Psychology, more likely than not, they have some thinking errors, they have some misunderstandings, some inaccurate beliefs about some things that has caused them to be troubled. And then the brain is adapting and functioning in a way that's manifesting them to feel low mood to feel depressed and Say if a person gets nothing but talk therapy, which I'm a huge believer in If a person receives talk therapy and they feel better if we were to do a brain map before they did the talk therapy And did no neuro just simply talk therapy and did a brain map when they were feeling better,
还有一些生理因素输入到其中。心理方面，很有可能，他们有一些思维错误，他们有一些误解，对某些事情有一些不准确的信念，导致他们感到困扰。然后大脑正在适应并以一种表现出他们感到情绪低落、感到抑郁的方式运作。如果一个人只接受谈话疗法，我是它的忠实信徒。如果一个人接受谈话疗法并且感觉好转，如果我们要在他们做谈话疗法之前做一个脑图，
there would be significant improvement from pre to post. The brain would be functioning much less like a typical person who's depressed, like that kind of a functionality. So the brain reorganizes as the emotions change. So with neuro-therapy, we're mechanically creating pathways, weakening maladaptive pathways, when I say pathways, connections between regions, helping the brain reorganize to be able to be a healthy functioning brain. You still have to do the psychological work.
并且不做任何神经治疗，只是简单地进行谈话疗法，并在他们感觉好转时做一个脑图，从前到后会有显著的改善。大脑的功能会比一个典型的抑郁症患者的功能要好得多。所以大脑随着情绪的变化而重新组织。因此，通过神经治疗，我们正在机械地创建通路，削弱适应不良的通路，当我谈到通路时，是指区域之间的连接，帮助大脑重新组织成为一个健康运作的大脑。你仍然必须做心理工作。
You still have to iron out the faulty beliefs that you might have. You still have to do the psychological work. But it's kind of like walking through a forest. And if you're doing talk therapy alone, then you're walking through that forest with your machete and you're blazing a trail while you're walking it at the same time Kind of hard to do but it's very I mean people do it all the time. It's it's it's incredibly doable But with neuro therapy, it's like we're blazing that trail beforehand before you actually even begin to walk it And then when you do the talk therapy now, it's much easier to walk that trail because your brain is now ready to Now it's much easier to walk that trail because your brain is now ready to
你仍然必须理清你可能有的错误信念。你仍然必须做心理工作。但这有点像穿过森林。如果你只是单独进行谈话疗法，那么你就在用你的砍刀穿过那片森林，你在走它的同时也在开辟一条小径，这很难做到，但它非常，我的意思是人们一直在做。它非常，它是令人难以置信地可行的。但通过神经治疗，就像我们在你真正开始走之前就开辟了那条小径。然后当你进行谈话疗法时，现在走那条小径就容易多了，因为你的大脑现在准备好了，
regulate the brain is ready to do to reorganize around healthy beliefs and Psychological functionalities so wanted to get that out there That that we're kind of getting a head start when you're doing neuro therapy and talk to even either neuro therapy alone And then you talk therapy later or the better model in my opinion is concomitant Neurotherapy with talk therapy doing both at the same time. You can really make tracks and and feel better You can just expedite how a person can can feel more like themselves when you do both at the same time You know, we recommend that to people a lot I mean ultimately it's up recommend that to people a lot.
调节，大脑准备好围绕健康的信念和心理功能进行重新组织。所以想把这一点说出来，我们在做神经治疗时有点领先，当你做神经治疗和谈话疗法，或者单独做神经治疗，然后稍后进行谈话疗法，或者在我看来更好的模型是同时进行神经治疗和谈话疗法，同时做这两件事。你可以真正取得进展，感觉更好。当你同时做这两件事时，你可以加快一个人感觉更像他们自己的速度。你知道，我们经常向人们推荐这一点。我的意思是最终它取决于
Ultimately, it's up to the patient, but a lot of people have the best results when they're in talk therapy. I think brain spotting and things that treat acute trauma really quickly are useful to stabilize that, but things like the QEG brain mapping that change, just like emotion regulation and
病人，但很多人在进行谈话疗法时效果最好。我认为脑点疗法和那些能非常快地治疗急性创伤的东西对于稳定它是很有用的，但像QEG脑图这样改变情绪调节和
tolerance to distressing situations and your ability to focus under stress and the effect that anxiety have on the whole person, you know, how fast you just lose the ability to see the forest for the trees is I see that help a ton, especially in dopamine disorders that are very genetically predisposed and resistant to medication, especially in ADHD, especially in kids with autism and adults with autism. It just seems like there's things that is like, I never really could have got there and talked therapy.
对痛苦情况的耐受力，以及你在压力下专注的能力，以及焦虑对整个人的影响，你知道，你失去见树不见林的能力的速度，我看到这非常有帮助，特别是在多巴胺紊乱中，这些紊乱在遗传上是预先决定的，并且对药物有抗药性，特别是在ADHD中，特别是在患有自闭症的儿童和成人中。这看起来就像有些事情是我在谈话疗法中永远无法达到的。
Like, you know what you're supposed to do, you know how to do it. It's not emotion recognition that's the problem. It's not trauma that's the problem. Your brain just is likely to lose its ability to function when there's this amount of stress. And I see QAG and Neuromod enhance that a lot for my people. Yes, and also, relief has a big part of this.
就像，你知道你应该做什么，你知道怎么做。不是情绪识别的问题。不是创伤的问题。你的大脑只是在有这种压力时容易失去功能。我看到QEG和神经调节对我的病人有很大帮助。是的，而且，缓解在其中起着很大的作用。
Sometimes people say, I sleep eight hours a day, but the brain is not actually resting and we can see that on the scene so if a person says okay, I sleep eight hours or Talking to him or wake up in the middle of an outing on the back of his face We can see one person has four feet and you can help that and a lot of times When the brain is able to rest better then other things start coming through automatically.
有时人们说，我每天睡八个小时，但大脑实际上并没有休息，我们可以在屏幕上看到这一点。所以如果一个人说，好的，我睡八个小时，或者和他交谈，或者在一次郊游中醒来，我们可以看到一个人有四个阶段，你可以帮助它。很多时候，当大脑能够更好地休息时，其他事情就会自动开始好转。
That's because your brain has been functioning with 3% battery for so long that you kind of got used to it. But then you realize how high you've been after you have done ament in your eyes? Okay, yes, I am not saving trouble. And the brain is actually going through the proper sleep cycle. We've had people that were, you know, those watchers or overings that, you know, practice sleep and sleep after the treatment starts. Well, that was the effect on me that I was kind of wanting to just feel better in a certain capacity and then I did and I felt tired and then I slept better and then I started to feel better. Just, you know, a lot of what you guys are doing is I think kind of stabilizing things
那是因为你的大脑长期处于3%的电量下运行，你已经习惯了。但当你做完治疗后，你会意识到自己之前的状态有多亢奋。好吧，是的，我不是在自找麻烦。大脑实际上正在经历正常的睡眠周期。我们遇到过一些人，你知道，那些守夜者或过度思考者，在治疗开始后，他们开始练习睡眠并能睡着了。对我来说，这种效果就是我只想在某种程度上感觉更好，然后我做到了，我感到疲倦，然后我睡得更好，接着我开始感觉好转。你知道，你们所做的很多事情，我认为是在稳定某些东西。
that we're maybe overcompensating for, you know, internally so that the system can just kind of go back into flux. It's like engaging the natural healing mechanisms that the brain has anyway, but just faster, you know, giving a little push to start to be more in equilibrium. Are you familiar, Jay, with any of... I noticed that a ton of people that are familiar with the older kind of depth psychology, Jungian analytical psychology stuff, are mistrustful of the newer neuroscience, brain-based medicine stuff, and then vice versa.
我们可能在内部过度补偿了这些东西，以便系统能够恢复到流动状态。这就像是启动了大脑本身就有的自然愈合机制，只是速度更快，你知道，给它一点推动力，让它开始达到更平衡的状态。Jay，你熟悉任何……我注意到很多熟悉旧式深度心理学、荣格分析心理学的人，对较新的神经科学、基于大脑的医学持怀疑态度，反之亦然。
There's a few people that people that are in both worlds, but they really, it seems like are saying the same thing. One with a technological metaphor and one with something else. Are you familiar with the John Bibi model of the MBTI or anything like that? It is fine. No more than the average. I have a cursory Understanding of that of that so I'm not really able to go in depth
有一些人同时涉足这两个领域，但他们似乎在说同样的事情。一个用技术隐喻，另一个用别的东西。你熟悉约翰·比比（John Bibi）的MBTI模型或类似的东西吗？还可以。了解程度不比一般人多。我对此只有粗浅的了解，所以无法深入探讨。
Well, just a lot of the things that he says are that you know, I mean not talking about you know He probably doesn't know that QG brain mapping exists and he's talking from Mike analytical psychology perspective like that The brain basically has four or five modes of cognition, but they're mutually exclusive. Some of them are mutually exclusive to another one. They cannot do them at the same time and that the problems that happen in talk therapy when you do that test are around people who over-prefer one type of cognition. So they're trying to solve every problem with one type of thinking and he says that any therapy modality that works, what it's doing is it's teaching you to get comfortable
嗯，他说的很多东西，我的意思是，不是在谈论你，他可能不知道QG脑图的存在，他是从迈克尔·分析心理学的角度出发的，即大脑基本上有四五种认知模式，但它们是互斥的。其中一些是相互排斥的。它们不能同时进行。在谈话疗法中出现的问题，当你做那个测试时，往往是因为人们过度偏好某一种认知类型。所以他们试图用一种思维方式解决所有问题，他说任何有效的治疗方式，其实都是在教你适应
with the type of cognition that you don't like. You know, it's having the introvert go, you know what, I can't find all the answers in this inner world. Sometimes I have to come outside and engage with other people and then be able to solve a problem relationally. Sometimes it's saying the opposite, that you can't just call your sister on the phone
你不喜欢的认知类型。你知道，就是让内向者意识到，你知道吗，我不能在内心世界找到所有答案。有时我必须走出来，与他人互动，然后能够从关系层面解决问题。有时则是相反的，你不能每次难过时
every time you're sad, that you have to kind of go inside and self soothe. You know, thinking and feeling a lot of times or a dichotomy intuition and sensing, you know, the MBTI would say, you know are Are hard to do at the same time Because one of them is going into a place that has no objectivity and just kind of going with a gut feeling and then the other One is looking at really hard concrete data to say this is you know an objective Variable to make base information on but we this is, you know, an objective variable to make base information on but we need both, you know, I don't know, overlap between a lot of that is interesting
都给姐姐打电话，你必须学会向内自我安抚。你知道，思维和情感很多时候是二元对立的，直觉和感知，你知道，MBTI会说，很难同时做到，因为其中一个进入了一个没有客观性的地方，只是凭直觉行事，而另一个则是在看非常硬核的具体数据，说这是一个客观变量，以此为基础信息，但我们需要两者，你知道，我不知道，这两者之间的重叠很有趣。
to me. Yes, it is. It is. And I think that's pretty unequivocal really. It's we know that so putting that together with with with how we know a person changes, you know, you usually people usually people change in three domains. Usually behavior changes first, and then once behavior is shaped,
对我来说。是的，确实如此。我认为这非常明确。我们知道这一点，所以将其与我们所知的个人改变方式结合起来，你知道，通常人们在三个领域发生改变。通常行为先改变，然后一旦行为形成，
then cognitions are more easily shaped. And then once behavior is kind of on the road, your thought life is kind of on the road your thought life is kind of on the road then lastly emotions change so behavior thoughts and emotions emotions are the last thing usually the last things to change in a way it's kind of a shame because that's what we want like I want to feel better that's that's why I'm here I want to feel better that's the last thing that's going to change like likely the last thing and so if you can work on behavior first in terms of your basic hygiene basic social skills
认知就更容易形成。一旦行为步入正轨，你的思想生活步入正轨，最后才是情绪改变。所以行为、思想和情绪，情绪通常是最后改变的。在某种程度上这很遗憾，因为这正是我们想要的，比如我想感觉更好，这就是我来这里的原因，我想感觉更好，但这却是最后才会改变的东西，很可能是最后改变的。所以如果你能先从行为入手，比如基本的卫生习惯、基本的社交技能，
Like like you were talking about, you know for the introvert to let their friends friends kind of Kidnap them and take them out and go see a movie and have some dinner even if even if they're not feeling it just let them take them out and go see a movie and have some dinner. Even if they're not feeling it, just let them pick them out and then just get more external. Then with healthier, more balanced behavior, then it's easier to analyze and have a more balanced thought life. What kinds of thoughts do you allow to stay? Which ones do you begin to debate with and to see if you
就像你刚才说的，你知道，让内向者的朋友把他们“绑架”出去，去看电影、吃顿晚餐，即使他们当时没心情，也让他们带他们出去，去看电影、吃顿晚餐。即使他们没心情，也让他们带他们出去，变得更外向。然后，有了更健康、更平衡的行为，就更容易分析并拥有更平衡的思想生活。你允许什么样的想法停留？你开始与哪些想法进行辩论，看看是否
can get rid of the maladaptive thoughts, and then emotions come around from the other two. What you just said does coincide with what we know about human progression. Well, I think that right now, if you just looked at the average, I mean, there's some people doing interesting stuff some places, but it seems like cognitive science and neuroscience are almost like ahead of understanding how the brain works ahead of clinical psychology.
能摆脱那些适应不良的想法，然后情绪会随着前两者而改变。你刚才所说的确实与我们所知的人类进步相吻合。嗯，我认为现在，如果你看看平均水平，我的意思是，有些人在某些地方做着有趣的事情，但似乎认知科学和神经科学在理解大脑运作方面几乎领先于临床心理学。
I think some of that is that we want to be so reductive with these metaphors, and we want to pretend that the brain works on our terms when it just doesn't. Are you familiar with Joseph Ledoux or like Michael Kazaniga's books, or Antonio de Masso, any of those like consciousness guys? Yes. Yeah. I think that we tend to think about like, well, first off, if you're not familiar, Joseph Ledoux ejected rats with a drug that inhibits protein synthesis.
我认为其中一部分原因是，我们太想用这些隐喻进行简化，我们想假装大脑是按我们的方式运作的，但事实并非如此。你熟悉约瑟夫·勒杜（Joseph Ledoux）或迈克尔·加扎尼加（Michael Gazzaniga）的书，或者安东尼奥·达马西奥（Antonio Damasio），这些研究意识的人吗？是的。是的。我认为我们倾向于认为，首先，如果你不熟悉，约瑟夫·勒杜给老鼠注射了一种抑制蛋白质合成的药物。
Then he would show them, he would try and teach them to either get punishment or avoid, or not, I'm sorry, avoid punishment or get food. When the protein is inhibited, the brain can't make new memories. So that proves that you need protein synthesis to make these memories that are new. Then like Todd Sachter takes that further and says,
然后他会展示给它们看，他会试图教它们要么接受惩罚或避免，或者不，抱歉，避免惩罚或获得食物。当蛋白质被抑制时，大脑无法制造新的记忆。这证明了你需要蛋白质合成来制造这些新的记忆。然后像托德·萨克特（Todd Sachter）更进一步说，
the way that we think about long-term memory is not really right. It's not like it's just saved on the hard drive and that's what happened. We're always going back to it, revising it and being like emotionally, what does that narrative mean? One of the ways he proves that is when he injects the protein synthesis, long-term memory changes. So the brain is going back in, it's modifying it.
我们思考长期记忆的方式并不完全正确。它不像只是保存在硬盘上，然后就发生了。我们总是回到它，修改它，并在情感上思考这个叙事意味着什么。他证明这一点的方法之一是，当他注射蛋白质合成抑制剂时，长期记忆发生了改变。所以大脑正在回去，它正在修改它。
He's the one that proved that that PKM Zeta enzyme is crucial for making long-term memory. But it's not like the memory was formed and so it's there, the brain's going back in, it's trying to figure out what it means, it's trying to update it. And we're always making meaning of our lives in this fairly dynamic way.
他是证明PKM Zeta酶对制造长期记忆至关重要的那个人。但并不是说记忆一旦形成就固定在那里了，大脑正在回去，它试图弄清楚这意味着什么，它试图更新它。我们总是以这种相当动态的方式赋予我们的生活意义。
And I read a lot of research coming out of academic psych and it's like, they don't want it to work like that. You know, they want it to be a very cognitive and behavioral paradigm that cannot make the base of the brain as alive as it is and as meaningful as it is within consciousness, which is, I mean, that's my bigger ax to grind,
我读了很多来自学术心理学的研究，感觉他们不想让它那样运作。你知道，他们希望它是一个非常认知和行为的范式，不能让大脑的基础像它实际那样生动，像它在意识中那样有意义，这就是我更大的不满，
but I think it's relevant to what you guys do. Just because a ton of the people who come to Taproot, who come to y'all, who get get help have been told in cognitive behavioral therapy you know snap the rubber band and tell your anxiety to stop oh well if you can't if that doesn't work you need to take medication which just seems so silly you know but that is still the majority of the field at least in Alabama right now I think it's important what you say. So there's a recent, I don't want to say push, that sounds kind of superficial, but there's
但我认为这与你们所做的事情有关。仅仅因为很多来到Taproot的人，来到你们这里寻求帮助的人，在认知行为疗法中被告知，你知道，弹橡皮筋，告诉你的焦虑停止，哦，好吧，如果那不起作用，你需要吃药，这看起来太愚蠢了，你知道，但这仍然是该领域的大多数，至少在阿拉巴马州目前是这样。我认为你说得很重要。所以最近有一个，我不想说推动，那听起来有点肤浅，但有一个
a development, there's an appropriate link being gradually established between clinical work and cognitive neuroscience, clinicians and researchers. It's becoming less dichotomized these days to where if you speak a research language then the clinicians can't understand you, or if you speak clinician lingo then the researcher is laughing. But there's a bridge that's being created by the EEG work that we're doing by the different labs at UC Davis in California and UC San Diego. Those folks are really the heavy hitters in terms of cognitive neuroscience. And if you're familiar with MATLAB, if you're familiar with these different platforms that
发展，临床工作和认知神经科学、临床医生和研究人员之间正在逐渐建立一种适当的联系。这些天来，它变得不再那么二元对立，不会出现如果你说研究语言，临床医生就听不懂，或者如果你说临床术语，研究人员就嘲笑的情况。但我们正在通过我们所做的EEG工作，通过加州大学戴维斯分校和加州大学圣地亚哥分校的不同实验室建立一座桥梁。那些人是认知神经科学领域的重量级人物。如果你熟悉MATLAB，如果你熟悉这些不同的平台，
help us to learn more about the brain and use that data, that's where this is coming out of. And so clinicians and neuroscientists are now being able to go to parties together and be in the same room and, and communicate back and forth. Uh, it is a wonderful time. It is, this is a very exciting time. And I think that's why, uh, brain knowledge about how the brain, uh, processes and helps regulate our emotions.
帮助我们更多地了解大脑并利用这些数据，这就是它的来源。所以临床医生和神经科学家现在可以一起参加聚会，在同一个房间里，进行交流。嗯，这是一个美好的时代。是的，这是一个非常令人兴奋的时代。我认为这就是为什么，关于大脑如何处理和帮助调节我们情绪的知识，
Things are advancing at such a quick pace now. Research, as you guys both know, research is slow. It is like watching grass grow, but not so much in the cognitive universe. And all the funding, probably. Oh, yes, yes, Yes. Yes, indeed. Indeed. But our knowledge base is now moving at such a rapid pace. Now you have to try to keep up with it.
事情现在进展得如此之快。研究，正如你们俩所知，研究很慢。就像看着草生长一样，但在认知领域并非如此。而且所有的资金，可能也是。哦，是的，是的，是的。确实如此。确实。但我们的知识库现在正以如此快的速度发展。现在你必须努力跟上它。
Or else it'll just leave you and you're doing your half step behind. What's current and what's the absolute best? Well, there's decades where nothing happens and then a year where a decade happens like in our understanding of psych and you look at the history of the country, it's just kind of always been like that, you know. Like it jumps. But I mean, what you're saying is important because it's like, like we lost for a decade or two that the
否则它就会把你抛在后面，你就会落后半步。什么是当前的，什么是绝对最好的？嗯，有几十年的时间什么都没发生，然后一年内发生了一十年那么多的事，比如在我们对心理学的理解上，你看看这个国家的历史，它一直都是这样的，你知道。就像它会跳跃式发展。但我的意思是，你所说的是重要的，因为就像我们失去了十年或二十年，
role of psych research was to make clinical psychology better. There was like 20 years where clinical psychology and academic psychology were going in two different directions, which is not good. The point of it is not for you to have an impact factor. The point of it is not for us to corporatize academia. The point of it is for you to be able to help clinicians do their job and ultimately help people hopefully, you know, Yeah, I've got a
心理学研究的作用是让临床心理学变得更好。有大约20年的时间，临床心理学和学术心理学朝着两个不同的方向发展，这不好。它的目的不是为了让你有影响力因子。它的目的不是为了让我们将学术界企业化。它的目的应该是让你能够帮助临床医生做好他们的工作，并最终帮助人们，你知道，是的，我有一个
I've got a phd in physiological psychology, which is the study of how the physical affects the psychology, right? And we're all doing all doing psychophysiology, which is a study of how the psychology affects the physical doing psychophysiology, which is a study of how the psychology affects the physical. It goes both ways. And so I think for the first time now, people who are encamped or historically encamped in one of these partitions, now it's like, ah, yeah, there's, I need to get out of my bubble or else I am drastically uninformed. Yeah. And I mean, I think it's Karl Friston who said that like what the brain is doing is just trying to use past experience to anticipate the future to minimize uncertainty.
生理心理学博士学位，这是研究身体如何影响心理的学科，对吧？我们都在做心理生理学，这是研究心理如何影响身体的学科。它是双向的。所以我认为现在第一次，那些历史上驻扎在这些分区之一的人，现在就像，啊，是的，我需要走出我的泡沫，否则我就是严重的信息匮乏。是的。而且，我认为是卡尔·弗里斯顿（Karl Friston）说过，大脑所做的只是试图利用过去的经验来预测未来，以最大限度地减少不确定性。
We want to have the most certainty about the future that we can and so it's trying to take all these patterns that it learned and it's trying to turn those into a mode of understanding the future so that we feel like we will know what happens. You know, and if you're, the paradigm is not right. You know, like if the incentives in your house were bad, you know, if you're a trauma survivor or something, you know, the guesses that you're making about how the world works when you're out of that environment aren't good anymore. You know, a lot of what, you know, brain mapping, when anything's doing is just helping the brain adjust
我们想要对未来有尽可能多的确定性，所以它试图利用它学到的所有模式，并试图将它们转化为一种理解未来的模式，这样我们就觉得我们会知道会发生什么。你知道，如果你的范式不对。你知道，比如如果你家里的激励机制很糟糕，你知道，如果你是一个创伤幸存者之类的，你知道，当你离开那个环境时，你对世界如何运作的猜测就不再准确了。你知道，脑图所做的很多事情，只是帮助大脑调整
to a new reality so that your thought is effective, you know, at getting you the outcome that you want and understanding how things work and kind of having clarity, you know, which I think when you go too far into cognitive behaviorism, you lose that because it's trying to get this objective result, which in my mind is not always the point, you know, psychology. You know, when I did the brain mapping with you guys, I felt like I understood something about my body and about emotions that I didn't know before, but I couldn't tell you what that was. I couldn't say, well, I sat down and made a treatment plan and I wanted to sleep for six hours. Well, I did sleep
以适应新的现实，这样你的思维就能有效地为你带来你想要的结果，理解事物是如何运作的，并拥有清晰的思路，你知道，我认为当你走得太远进入认知行为主义时，你会失去这一点，因为它试图获得这种客观结果，在我看来，这并不总是重点，你知道，心理学。你知道，当我与你们一起做脑图时，我觉得我理解了一些关于我的身体和情绪的东西，这是我以前不知道的，但我无法告诉你那是什么。我不能说，好吧，我坐下来制定了一个治疗计划，我想睡六个小时。嗯，我确实睡了
more, but I couldn't say I wanted to go out and be more community involved or something, and then I did that. A lot of those behaviors happened, but it wasn't the point of the process for me the point of the process for me was that I understood that my back holds tension that I can breathe deeply that I can notice that I have more empathy for people when I'm speaking to them. Things that I you know were remembered that I used to know you know but that we lose touch with and kind of chaos and all this and I think to making things too objective and too empirical which you need to do research, but you lose when you're trying to make it a point of psychology in my perspective.
更多，但我不能说我想出去更多地参与社区活动之类的，然后我确实那样做了。很多那些行为发生了，但那不是我这个过程的重点，对我来说这个过程的重点是我理解了我的背部会积压紧张，我可以深呼吸，我可以注意到当我和人交谈时，我对他们有更多的同理心。这些事情我记得我曾经知道，但我们在混乱中失去了联系，我认为把事情变得太客观、太经验主义，虽然你需要做研究，但当你试图把它作为心理学的重点时，在我看来，你就失去了它。
And you guys remember the human, you know, even though you're messing with microchips and wavelengths, like you remember the human and what you do, which is wonderful. Wonderful. I think it's empowering for the person when they can see us overtly keeping that in mind. It's like, when a person comes into our office for a session, we pull up the brain map. And so just to have it there, we may not talk about it, may not go through it again, but it's up. And so if we ever just kind of looked at the brain map, just that if we do want to have more conversations about what we're doing, well, then there's the map.
而且你们记得人，你知道，尽管你们在摆弄微芯片和波长，但你们记得人以及你们所做的事情，这很棒。太棒了。我认为当人们看到我们公开地牢记这一点时，这对他们来说是赋能的。就像，当一个人走进我们的办公室进行治疗时，我们调出脑图。所以把它放在那里，我们可能不会谈论它，可能不会再看它，但它就在那里。所以如果我们曾经只是看一眼脑图，如果我们确实想就我们正在做的事情进行更多对话，好吧，那么地图就在那里。
We're trying to cool down this area because of these reasons, trying to increase this area because of these regions. It just gives us a talking point if we were so inclined on that day. But you're more than your brain. It's true that we're handcuffed to the brain. If it's not functioning as designed, we're going to be a little bit different, maybe a lot different. And we don't have a lot of choice in that matter. But we're more than our brains. I mean there is something called the spirit. There's something called the soul, you know, if you're gonna If you're going to talk to me, i'm going to give you these answers. So there's there's uh, there's there's there's more to the person than the brain
我们正在尝试冷却这个区域，因为这些原因，尝试增加这个区域，因为这些区域。它只是给了我们一个谈话点，如果我们那天有兴趣的话。但你不仅仅是你的大脑。我们确实被大脑束缚住了，这是真的。如果它没有按设计运作，我们就会有点不同，也许会有很大不同。在这件事上我们没有太多选择。但我们不仅仅是大脑。我的意思是有一种东西叫精神。有一种东西叫灵魂，你知道，如果你要跟我谈话，我会给你这些答案。所以，人的存在不仅仅是大脑。
Uh, and so I think it's empowering for the client For anyone that's that's that's listening to us talking about this field To To know that we all understand that it's not we're not just Brain mechanics and with our wrenches and we're trying to tweak this and adjust that well, I think what is it? Julia Tonoi? said that like, you know, consciousness is really just all of these different types of information that we have to process being blended in a certain way, you know, and then we don't, we can't like empirically ever really know where all of those streams of integrated
而且，我认为这对客户来说是赋能的，对于任何听我们谈论这个领域的人来说，知道我们都明白我们不仅仅是带着扳手的脑部机械师，我们试图调整这个和那个，嗯，我认为是什么？朱利奥·托诺尼（Giulio Tononi）？说过，你知道，意识实际上只是所有这些我们需要处理的信息以某种方式混合在一起，你知道，然后我们不能，我们永远无法凭经验真正知道所有那些成为意识的整合流
information that become consciousness are even coming from, you know, there's just, there's so much going on in the sub brain and feedback loops and feed forward loops from the neurons that we have in our gut. You know, the only place we have neurons other than our brain and the psycho physical reactions like but those do get put together in this experience of consciousness. And I think you have to be empirical what you can be empirical about and you have to leave room for the mystery where you can't and know that you can't very well said. Okay, Jay had to leave the room for a second So we're gonna let Deanna answer that question and then Jay will hop back on when he gets back
信息甚至是从哪里来的，你知道，大脑下部和反馈回路以及来自我们肠道神经元的反馈回路中发生的事情太多了。你知道，除了大脑之外，我们唯一有神经元的地方，以及心理物理反应，但这些确实被整合到了这种意识体验中。我认为你必须对你能凭经验确定的事情保持经验主义，并且你必须在不能确定的地方为神秘留出空间，并知道你不能。说得很好。好的，Jay刚才不得不离开房间一会儿，所以我们要让Deanna回答那个问题，然后Jay回来时会加入。
Yeah, you had to had to a change the protocol on somebody. Go ahead Wait, hold on. What was the question again? Well, you were talking about the show you were saying that you had a parallel to show severance I think that's as far as we've gone. Severance, yes. They implant a chip in a person's brain and it creates an artificial dissociative identity disorder where they don't know anything about the person inside of work
是的，你不得不更改某人的方案。继续。等等，等等。问题是什么来着？嗯，你在谈论那个节目，你说你有一个与《人生切割术》（Severance）平行的观点，我想这就是我们讨论的深度。Severance，是的。他们在人的大脑中植入芯片，创造了一种人工解离性身份障碍，他们对工作之外的人一无所知，
and the person inside of work doesn't know anything about the person inside of work and the person inside of work doesn't know anything about the person outside of work. So it's what I mean by that is it's very difficult to exactly explain what consciousness is because it can be I mean, is it awareness because that's all this psychological ethics stuff like the Michael Gazaniga where he talks about like you know when one half of the brain does not know language but it still has an opinion about something like in split brain patients that have had a bifurcation of the brain either due to an accident or due to surgery around an epilepsy or something you
而工作内部的人对工作外部的人一无所知。所以我的意思是，很难准确解释什么是意识，因为它可能是，我的意思是，它是意识吗？因为那都是心理伦理学的东西，比如迈克尔·加扎尼加（Michael Gazzaniga），他谈到，你知道，当大脑的一半不懂语言，但它仍然对某事有看法时，比如在裂脑患者中，由于事故或癫痫手术等原因导致大脑分叉，
can you can detect two types of consciousness that are in conflict, you know, so what is the person? You know, is it the part that can talk in words or is it? Is it anything that is you know alive for the lack of a better word? Yes, exactly The severance you see can you tell us about severance? I think I saw the pilot. I haven't I haven't gone further Yeah, so basically they implant the chip into people's brains and they wake up at work one day.
你可以检测到两种处于冲突中的意识，你知道，所以人是什么？你知道，是那个能用语言说话的部分吗？还是？是任何你知道，用缺乏更好的词来说，活着的东西吗？是的，完全正确。Severance，你能告诉我们关于Severance的事吗？我想我看了试播集。我还没看下去。是的，所以基本上他们把芯片植入人们的大脑，他们有一天在工作中醒来。
And the main character, he's mourning the loss of his wife. He gets fired from his job, so he decides to do the severance procedure. So he goes to work, he has no idea what he does for work. Then once he goes into the elevator, he even talks differently. So a new personality is emerging around the experiences he's had at work. It's the one he's had.
主角，他正在哀悼妻子的去世。他被解雇了，所以他决定进行Severance手术。所以他去上班，他根本不知道自己是做什么工作的。然后一旦他进入电梯，他甚至说话的方式都变了。所以一个新的个性正在围绕他在工作中经历的事情出现。这就是他所拥有的。
Yeah. It's almost like two different people. Well, that is one of those neuroscience things that's interesting is it's like the different structures of the brain were sort of designed to think a certain way and they can, but you can also just cut half of it off and the structures can be repurposed like those networks are fairly m graphics card if you want, it won't work as well. But if your graphics card breaks, you can use the integrated graphics processing on the CPU. You can take different types of processing structures and then the network can handle them differently. And I think brains are moving networks around like that all the time. And you're right, that is what you see in DID, where somebody, there wasn't enough ego integrity ever for the memory to be associated with like one persona it became this kind of expansive thing that were all extreme reactions to different extreme environments. Yeah, yes. And yes the network the networks and the brain do organize. So if seen in patients with epilepsy that have had one of their temporal lobes,
是的。这几乎就像两个人。嗯，这是神经科学中一件有趣的事情，就像大脑的不同结构被设计成以某种方式思考，它们可以，但你也可以切掉它的一半，结构可以被重新利用，就像那些网络相当……如果你愿意的话，就像显卡，它不会工作得那么好。但如果你的显卡坏了，你可以使用CPU上的集成显卡处理。你可以采用不同类型的处理结构，然后网络可以以不同的方式处理它们。我认为大脑一直在那样移动网络。你是对的，这就是你在DID中看到的，一个人没有足够的自我完整性来让记忆与一个角色相关联，它变成了一种扩张的东西，都是对不同极端环境的极端反应。是的，是的。是的，大脑中的网络确实会组织起来。所以如果在患有癫痫的患者中看到，他们的一侧颞叶，
respected from the brain, and yes, they do have some memory loss. However, they can still function day-to-day and a lot of times without epilepsy because the focus has been resected. Yeah, I wonder too about like we were talking about memory how the brain can assign different meanings to the same long-term memory that it's there's not really a thing like I mean long-term memory short-term memory function differently biologically but it's not the same long-term memory. There's not really a thing like, I mean, long-term memory and short-term memory function differently biologically, but it's not like the long-term memory is static, it's still changing.
从大脑中切除，是的，他们确实有一些记忆丧失。然而，他们仍然可以进行日常运作，而且很多时候没有癫痫，因为病灶已经被切除了。是的，我也在想关于我们谈论的记忆，大脑如何为同一个长期记忆分配不同的含义，它并不是真的有一件事，我的意思是长期记忆和短期记忆在生物学上运作方式不同，但它不是同一个长期记忆。并不是真的有一件事，我的意思是长期记忆和短期记忆在生物学上运作方式不同，但长期记忆并不是静态的，它仍然在改变。
Because our relationship to it and what it means about us and our identity is changing. Like, do you see a lot of precuneal dysregulation in certain types of trauma? Because my suspicion about, I do more brain-spotting, but a lot of the clinic, I think everybody now except for me does lifespan integration at the clinic,
因为我们与它的关系以及它对我们和我们的身份意味着什么正在改变。比如，你在某些类型的创伤中看到很多楔前叶（precuneal）失调吗？因为我的怀疑是，我做更多的脑点（brain-spotting），但诊所里我想除了我之外每个人都在做寿命整合（lifespan integration），
which is this kind of therapy where there's a lot of techniques, but you're basically digging up different moments in people's life where they had a really strong conception of who they were and what their values were. But it conflicted with what I believed later. And you make them experience all of those kind of on a timeline really quickly, and you smush it up until every year, like this is what you have to be.
这是一种有很多技术的疗法，但你基本上是在挖掘人们生活中他们对自己的身份和价值观有强烈概念的不同时刻。但它与我后来相信的东西相冲突。你让他们在时间轴上非常快地体验所有这些，你把它们挤在一起，直到每一年，就像这就是你必须成为的样子。
No, actually, it's this. No, this is actually what it is until those things kind of war and fall apart. And you're left with this core identity of who you are without all of the things that you sort of had to identify with at different times. And my theory about how those work is that it's, it's messing with the precuneus' ability to assign significance to different periods of time that you're kind of playing with time there. So I was curious if, if that's something that you see,
不，实际上，是这个。不，这实际上是什么，直到那些东西发生冲突并分崩离析。你留下了你是谁的核心身份，而没有了你在不同时期不得不认同的所有东西。关于它们如何工作的理论是，它在干扰楔前叶为不同时间段分配意义的能力，你是在那里玩弄时间。所以我很好奇，如果这是你看到的，
you see on cues, I don't know. So every memory that we store in the brain is associated with emotion. So if we have a traumatic experience, then it's associated with an emotion and you are more likely to remember it. And same with happy experiences. So the long-term memory usually has a lot of emotion associated to it. Sometimes there are points and we saw this when I did the brain spotting with E2, that there were aspects,
你在QG上看到的，我不知道。所以我们存储在大脑中的每一个记忆都与情绪相关联。所以如果我们有创伤经历，那么它就与一种情绪相关联，你更有可能记住它。快乐的经历也是如此。所以长期记忆通常与很多情绪相关联。有时有一些点，当我们做脑点治疗时，我看到了这一点，有些方面，
and I never thought about it, aspects of my own personality that became that way because of a traumatic event, which at the beginning I didn't think that it was going to be a traumatic event, but it did affect how I view the world and personality. So we do see often trauma in the brain when we do EEGs. And we have had experience with people with PTSD and trauma. We can see it and it stems from different ways that like we explained before that everyone's brain behaves differently
我从未想过，我自己的个性中有些方面是因为创伤事件而变成那样的，起初我并不认为那会是一个创伤事件，但它确实影响了我看待世界和个性的方式。所以当我们做EEG时，我们确实经常看到大脑中的创伤。我们有PTSD和创伤患者的经验。我们可以看到它，它源于不同的方式，就像我们之前解释的那样，每个人的大脑表现不同，
and everyone's brain is different. But we do see some of the markers of trauma in the brain. And oftentimes when we start treating that trauma, it brings up those memories, not in the same way because of the treatment, you cannot see it a little more calmly, but it can bring up nightmares. And when your brain has been stuck, not wanting to remember the trauma,
每个人的大脑都不同。但我们确实在大脑中看到了一些创伤的标志。而且通常当我们开始治疗那种创伤时，它会带出那些记忆，因为治疗的原因，不会以同样的方式，你可以更冷静地看待它，但它可能会带出噩梦。当你的大脑一直卡住，不想记住创伤，
and then all of a sudden it is out in the open. You feel that in your body and it can bring up some. Some nightmares and and that relieving some of the trauma however is not going gonna be as if you're living it again, but your body does remember, even if you don't want to. Well, the emotions are tied, or the memories are tied to emotions, and emotions are partially a somatic reaction when there's a mismatch between what we need and what the environment is, you know. So it would make sense you couldn't have one without the other. Yeah. Yeah, that is interesting and we see too, you know, nightmares being
然后突然它暴露在光天化日之下。你在身体里感觉到它，它可能会带出一些。一些噩梦，而且缓解一些创伤，然而，不会像你再次经历它一样，但你的身体确实记得，即使你不想记得。嗯，情绪是联系在一起的，或者记忆是与情绪联系在一起的，而情绪在我们需要的东西和环境之间不匹配时，部分是一种躯体反应，你知道。所以如果你不能两者兼得，那是有道理的。是的。是的，这很有趣，我们也看到，你知道，噩梦被
triggered when we go in and look at trauma with brain spotting or with ETT or with lifespan integration or a lot of the other, you know, clinical things that we do. We had an interview last week with the host of the This Young Gain Life podcast about dreams and that was one of the things is like, that a lot of times dreams are this way of trying to make sense of the future with the past and trying to get information that, you know, trying to like know something that we don't really want to know. And when the ego is turned off and we don't have our other defense mechanisms, the brain is like, here you go. You know, here's, here's the thing
触发，当我们进入并用脑点治疗或ETT或寿命整合或我们做的许多其他临床事情来看待创伤时。我们上周采访了《This Young Gain Life》播客的主持人，关于梦，这是其中之一，就像，很多时候梦是试图用过去来理解未来，并试图获得信息，你知道，试图知道一些我们并不真正想知道的事情。当自我关闭，我们没有其他防御机制时，大脑就像，给你。你知道，这是，这是你需要接受的事情，
that you need to accept and a repetitive dream. You see that clinically, like people that have had the same dream for years and years and years. If you can really kind of get at the core of what it's saying. And sometimes they can't hear it from the dream, you know, they're not going to get it from dream work. You know what it means as a clinician. But when they accept that thing that they're avoiding knowing, then all of a sudden that's when the repetitive dream goes away. You never have it again because you don't need to be told that this is something that
一个重复的梦。你在临床上看到这一点，就像人们多年来一直做同一个梦。如果你真的能触及它所说的核心。有时他们无法从梦中听到它，你知道，他们不会从梦境工作中得到它。作为临床医生，你知道它意味着什么。但当他们接受了他们避免知道的事情时，突然间这就是重复的梦消失的时候。你再也不会有它了，因为你不需要被告知这是某件事，
you have to kind of accept when your defenses are down, when you're asleep. And the overlap between all that, it's really interesting. Jay's back. Hello gang. I apologize for my brief absence. So and the overlap between all that it's really interesting Jay's back Hello gang, I apologize for my brief absence. I hope I wasn't too interruptive now you're fine Do you do you want to just kind of go through? Kind of how you seen the technology change over time just the history of the technology and then we could maybe do one or two Specific case studies and I know you off got other stuff you need to get to you
当你防御降低、睡觉时，你必须接受它。所有这些之间的重叠，真的很有趣。Jay回来了。大家好。我为我短暂的缺席道歉。所以所有这些之间的重叠，真的很有趣。Jay回来了。大家好。我为我短暂的缺席道歉。我希望我没有太打扰你们。现在你很好。你，你想要，你想要只是，你知道，过一遍吗？你如何看待技术随时间的变化，只是技术的历史，然后我们可以也许做一两个具体的案例研究，我知道你们还有其他事情需要处理。
Sure. Sure. Yeah happy to So right brain change really has sort of Progressed from from its early days, you know, most people are pretty familiar with neurofeedback Which is a paradigm where you're apparently rewarding certain kinds of EEG functionality. So you're measuring EEG, and then you're rewarding the good stuff. If we see that from the person's brain map and their history,
当然。当然。是的，很高兴。所以大脑改变确实已经从早期发展而来，你知道，大多数人对神经反馈（neurofeedback）非常熟悉，这是一种范式，你显然是在奖励某种EEG功能。所以你在测量EEG，然后你在奖励好的东西。如果我们从人的脑图和他们的历史中看到，
that they would be feeling better if they were potentiating more of what we call beta, a certain wavelength that we call beta, then we can measure, the EEG while a person is wearing a couple of implements on the head. And then we can reinforce the brain, reinforce the person every time that the brain potentially more beta as for just for talking points. So neurofeedback has been around for a while. It, it, it works. It's always worked.
如果他们能增强更多我们称之为beta的东西，一种我们称之为beta的特定波长，他们会感觉更好，那么我们可以测量，当一个人头上戴着几个工具时，EEG。然后我们可以强化大脑，每当大脑增强更多beta时，就强化那个人，只是作为谈话点。所以神经反馈已经存在一段时间了。它，它，它有效。它一直有效。
Um, it's just a little bit slow sometimes trying to catch the brain doing something good, and then you reward it and then encourage the brain to keep on doing, doing that functionality. It's just kind of a slow gradual process, but it works and it's a very good non-pharmaceutical option for people who want to sharpen their brain or to address some kind of a clinical aspect. Recently, the knowledge has come about that cells copy frequencies. We didn't know that until about maybe 20 years ago, maybe 25 years ago, that if a frequency in the form of EMF or AC, if a frequency touches the brain, then after just a couple of minutes,
嗯，只是有时试图捕捉大脑做某件好事有点慢，然后你奖励它，然后鼓励大脑继续做，做那个功能。这只是一种缓慢的渐进过程，但它有效，对于那些想要磨练大脑或解决某种临床方面的人来说，这是一个非常好的非药物选择。最近，人们了解到细胞会复制频率。我们直到大约20年前，也许25年前才知道这一点，如果频率以EMF或AC的形式，如果频率接触大脑，那么仅仅几分钟后，
call it 10 minutes, 15 minutes, now the brain will be oscillating at that exact speed. So it just mimics frequencies. Why is that, Jay? Is there some sort of evolutionary benefit to taking external frequencies and mimicking them, or is that just kind of a spandrel effect that the brain talks to each other that way? So you can use an external source to kind of pretend to be a neuron and, and stimulate
称之为10分钟，15分钟，现在大脑将以那个精确的速度振荡。所以它只是模仿频率。为什么会这样，Jay？将外部频率引入并模仿它们有什么进化上的好处吗，还是那只是大脑以那种方式相互交谈的拱肩效应？所以你可以使用外部源来假装是一个神经元，并刺激
it and it just thinks it's part of a bigger structure while that's happening. What is it that causes the mimicry? I think the latter is the case. It does. It does cause, yeah, the anions and cations involved in a cell's propagation of the impulse. I think the EMF, we know that it does augment calcium channel gates. And so it just on a very gentle level, frequencies cause cells to fire at that pace. It just depolarizes the cells and causes them to
它，当这种情况发生时，它只是认为它是更大结构的一部分。是什么导致了这种模仿？我认为后者是事实。它确实。它确实导致，是的，细胞冲动传播中涉及的阴离子和阳离子。我认为EMF，我们知道它确实增强了钙通道门。所以它只是在一个非常温和的层面上，频率导致细胞以那个速度放电。它只是使细胞去极化并导致它们
function just like the Pied Piper. It just mechanically hits the on switch. The cap when you're doing the neuro stimulation is just pretending to be part of the brain and telling the brain, hey, I'm a neuron, like it's a narc at a dead show or something. It telling the brain, Hey, I'm a neuron, you know, like it's a narc at a dead show or something. And it's, it's telling you like, Hey, I'm a neuron. You got it. This is what you want to do on the top level of neurons.
像吹笛人一样运作。它只是机械地按下开关。当你做神经刺激时，帽子只是假装是大脑的一部分，并告诉大脑，嘿，我是一个神经元，就像死头乐队（dead show）上的卧底警察一样。它告诉大脑，嘿，我是一个神经元，你知道，就像死头乐队上的卧底警察一样。而且，它正在告诉你，嘿，我是一个神经元。你明白了。这是你想在神经元顶层做的事情。
Just like that. Just like that. You think it sounds like that? Hey. Yeah. Yes. We're telling the, the, yeah. Let's, let's start firing these frequencies a little bit more.
就像那样。就像那样。你认为听起来像那样吗？嘿。是的。是的。我们正在告诉，那个，是的。让我们，让我们开始更多地触发这些频率。
What is that? Yeah, it works faster than near feedback. Because near feedback, like Jay said, you have to catch the brain doing something good and don't reward it. Just like an example that I like to use is, uh, when you are raising a child and then you see the bad behavior, uh, and the good behavior. So catching children, you know, doing good things sometimes it's hard, especially at the beginning.
那是什么？是的，它比神经反馈工作得更快。因为神经反馈，就像Jay说的，你必须捕捉大脑做某件好事，而不是奖励它。就像我喜欢用的一个例子，嗯，当你抚养孩子时，然后你看到坏行为，嗯，和好行为。所以捕捉孩子们，你知道，做好的事情有时很难，特别是在开始时。
But if you tell the child, okay, uh, maybe don't pull the dog's hair. Just let me show you how to pet the dog. So the child is more likely to learn how to be gentle with the dog by showing them how to do it, then, then, you know, punishing or rewarding when they do it. Correctly or not. Well, and one of the technologies that people are more familiar with, it's a little bit older, is what in all these terms,
但如果你告诉孩子，好吧，嗯，也许不要拉狗的毛。让我给你展示如何抚摸狗。所以孩子更有可能通过向他们展示如何做，来学习如何对狗温柔，而不是，然后，你知道，在他们做的时候惩罚或奖励。正确与否。嗯，人们更熟悉的技术之一，它有点老，是什么，在所有这些术语中，
you may hear them used interchangeably because it's not like there is a rule about not, I mean, people call stuff brain mapping, and I wouldn't call brain mapping because you're not mapping the brain, but I guess they're allowed to do that. But one of the older technologies is what generally is called biofeedback, which is where you give the person a readout of all of their types of QG frequency. My high beta is a red spaceship and my theta wave is a green spaceship,
你可能会听到它们被交替使用，因为并不是说有一个关于不的规则，我的意思是，人们称之为脑图，我不会称之为脑图，因为你不是在绘制大脑，但我猜他们被允许这样做。但较老的技术之一是通常被称为生物反馈（biofeedback）的东西，即你给那个人他们所有QG频率类型的读数。我的高beta是一个红色飞船，我的theta波是一个绿色飞船，
and they say, okay, well, the green spaceship is too low. The patient has to sit there while they're actively being monitored in it and think, how do I erase this? Oh, it's that type of cognition. Oh, good. And they kind of reward their own brain, but that's one, assuming that they're gonna spend enough time and figure that out.
他们说，好吧，嗯，绿色飞船太低了。病人必须坐在那里，当他们被主动监测时，思考，我该如何擦除这个？哦，是那种认知类型。哦，好。他们以某种方式奖励他们自己的大脑，但这是一种，假设他们会花足够的时间并弄清楚这一点。
And then two, research says that that takes about 65-ish sessions to work. Whereas what you guys are doing is mapping the brain, seeing what they need, then immediately making the brain automatically mimic that frequency even if the patient isn't participating intellectually. I was doing emails while I was doing mine, but you-all were trying to pull me out of mania basically.
然后第二，研究说这大约需要65次左右的疗程才能起作用。而你们正在做的是绘制大脑，看看他们需要什么，然后立即让大脑自动模仿那个频率，即使病人没有在智力上参与。我在做我的邮件时，我正在做我的，但你们基本上是在试图把我从躁狂中拉出来。
While I'm doing emails, I could feel something trying to make me relax and I could feel something else being like, No, stop it, I need this, stop it. You know, reached out. Then afterwards, I had a great nap. But like y'all's, you know, it's, it's similar to that, you know, using QEG to help somebody modify things, but you're kind of doing it for them, because this is expensive it's time-consuming and people got stuff to do and so being able to make significant progress and then remap and see what that was in ten sessions versus you know the 65 that research says is what you would need for biofeedback is an improvement on the tech I would say. Yes and it also helps for children. Yeah, you can't explain to kids how to remove the red spaceship, especially now they're
当我在处理邮件时，我能感觉到有什么东西试图让我放松，同时又能感觉到另一种东西在说：“不，停下，我需要这个，停下。”你知道，就是那种触动。之后，我睡了个好觉。但就像你们的一样，你知道，这很相似，利用QEG来帮助某人改善状况，但你实际上是在替他们做，因为这很昂贵，也很耗时，而且人们还有别的事要做，所以能够在十次疗程内取得显著进展并重新绘制脑图，看看效果如何，相比研究表明生物反馈所需的65次疗程，我认为这是技术上的一种进步。是的，这对儿童也有帮助。是的，你无法向孩子们解释如何移除红色宇宙飞船，尤其是现在他们
going to look for a button or touch the screen, you know, like they don't- Yes. Yes. So when we have children in the spectrum or ADHD, a lot of them, especially children in the spectrum, they will, the parents would bring a tablet or something and the kid can be playing, you know, doing something, watching while they're receiving the treatment. And that is a good distraction when we have, you know, something on their heads, which usually, you know, sensorial input is strong. So putting something on their head sometimes it's a lot for them.
会去寻找按钮或触摸屏幕，你知道，他们不会——是的。是的。所以当我们有患有自闭症谱系障碍或多动症（ADHD）的孩子时，他们中的许多人，尤其是自闭症谱系的孩子，父母会带一个平板电脑之类的东西，孩子在接受治疗时可以玩游戏或看东西。当我们把东西放在他们头上时，这是一种很好的分散注意力的方式，通常你知道，感官输入是很强烈的。所以把东西放在他们头上对他们来说有时负担太重了。
And having, giving them something to do helps distract from, you know, having that helmet on their head. Well, could we end with maybe just a case study, just an example so people understand of like, if I come in with average ADHD or average autism spectrum disorder and I'm complaining about getting overwhelmed by sensory stuff, if I get something slimy on my hands washing dishes or I'm around hot or cold, I flood. And what does that look like on a map? You know, and so how do you, you know, show that to a patient? And then after you do that, what would the plan be like, you know, those sessions in order to change that?
给他们找点事做有助于分散他们对头上戴着头盔的注意力。那么，我们能不能以一个案例研究作为结束，举个例子让大家理解，比如，如果我带着典型的多动症或典型的自闭症谱系障碍来就诊，并且抱怨感官过载，如果我洗碗时手上沾了黏糊糊的东西，或者处于过热或过冷的环境中，我就会崩溃。这在脑图上是什么样子的？你知道，你是如何向病人展示这一点的？在你这样做之后，为了改变这种情况，治疗计划会是什么样的，比如那些疗程？
And then what are we hoping to see on the remap and what do we do if it doesn't completely resolve on the remap? Could you just take us through a hypothetical there so people maybe understand a little bit more about how to use it? Because we want to work with therapists in the community. I mean, there's people who want to work with the brain maps and we're happy to comp some people's map because we want you to, that's how I learned how to use it as a therapist.
然后我们希望在重新绘制脑图时看到什么？如果重新绘制后问题没有完全解决，我们该怎么办？你能带我们过一遍假设的情况吗，这样人们也许能更好地理解如何使用它？因为我们想与社区中的治疗师合作。我的意思是，有些人想使用脑图，我们很乐意免费提供一些人的脑图，因为我们希望你们这样做，这就是我作为一名治疗师学习使用它的方式。
That's how we hope community therapists will be able to use this technology in this area. And if you're not in Alabama, find somebody who does something similar to J&Giana if you're in Texas or if you're somewhere where you can find another firm that's doing a similar thing. I'd love for the treatments in psychology
这就是我们希望社区治疗师能够在该领域使用这项技术的方式。如果你不在阿拉巴马州，如果你在德克萨斯州，或者在其他地方能找到做类似事情的公司，那就找一个做类似J&Giana所做工作的人。我希望心理学治疗
to be more integrated and more cohesive. And I think that's one of the ways we get there so could you just kind of explain for you know for therapists so they could maybe understand how this could enhance you deciding the kind of therapy and support the therapy that you are doing you know with this technology sure sure and to your point yeah I was I was recently approached by a spine surgeon here in Dallas that they're going to begin to treat individuals with developmental delays, putting together like a neuroscience institute and treat people, think people with hyperbaric oxygen
能更加整合和连贯。我认为这是我们实现这一目标的方法之一，所以你能为治疗师解释一下吗，让他们了解这项技术如何能增强你决定治疗类型和支持你正在进行的治疗的能力？当然，当然，说到你的观点，是的，最近达拉斯的一位脊柱外科医生找到我，他们将开始治疗发育迟缓的个体，组建一个类似神经科学研究所的机构，治疗人们，考虑用高压氧
and red light therapy that we can talk about if we want to talk about, but they're interested in somebody like me come in and do brain mapping, do pre and post to show the efficacy of those treatments and guide the regimen of what they're delivering. of what they're delivering. So yes, I think that we would all benefit if we all do work together. You ever tried it with ketamine, IV ketamine patients or are there any studies on that? I've wondered if the neuroplasticity,
和红光疗法来治疗，如果我们想谈的话可以谈谈，但他们对像我这样的人感兴趣，让我去进行脑图绘制，做治疗前后的对比，以显示这些治疗的有效性，并指导他们所提供的治疗方案。所以是的，我认为如果我们都一起工作，我们都会受益。你有没有尝试过氯胺酮，静脉注射氯胺酮的病人，或者有没有关于这方面的研究？我一直想知道神经可塑性，
if the brain kind of being more malleable and memory being sort of less consolidated would mean that you had rapid change or maybe something bad happens. I don't know. I'll be the guy. I don't know as much about that as I would like and maybe as much as I should at this point, because it's been around for a little bit now. Have you have you read much,
如果大脑变得更具可塑性，记忆变得不那么巩固，是否意味着你会经历快速的变化，或者可能会发生不好的事情。我不知道。我来当那个提问的人吧。我对这方面的了解不如我希望的那样多，也许也不如我现在应该了解的那样多，因为它已经存在一段时间了。你读过很多吗，
Diana, about about about microdosing or about the ketamine We we did have a a client that was on ketamine every two weeks and it was pretty much the highest dose you could get and um They came the the uh treatment with us Um, we could not do it longer because it was an out of state client.
戴安娜，关于微剂量或关于氯胺酮的？我们确实有一位客户每两周使用一次氯胺酮，剂量几乎是你能得到的最高剂量，嗯，他们来接受我们的治疗，嗯，我们无法进行更长时间的治疗，因为那是外州的客户。
So we did just, you know, not as many sessions as we would like, but I got a call from that person a few weeks later that their ketamine treatment actually had been reduced. No, it was oral. Yeah, lower dose. Was that an oral ketamine though? I am not entirely sure. I don't really remember. Usually the IV, usually the IV is like, uh, you just get six to nine sessions of pretty intense stuff.
所以我们只是，你知道，没有进行我们想要的那么多疗程，但我几周后接到了那个人的电话，说他们的氯胺酮治疗实际上已经减少了。不，那是口服的。是的，剂量更低。那是口服氯胺酮吗？我不完全确定。我不太记得了。通常静脉注射，通常静脉注射就像，嗯，你只需要进行六到九次非常强烈的疗程。
Whereas the oral and then the nasal or something that you take over time So I was curious how they were sounds like they've been prescribed it for a while reduced. Yeah. Yeah, they have been on it for a while Well, if we if we all work together I tell colleagues and we all talk about this that There could be 10 neuro-therapists down the hallway. We could all office in the same building on the same floor and we would not take clients from one another. I mean, there's that kind of a need for treatment and sharpening.
而口服和鼻喷雾剂之类的东西是你随着时间推移而使用的，所以我很好奇他们的情况，听起来他们已经被开了很长一段时间了，减少了。是的，是的，他们已经使用很长一段时间了。好吧，如果我们都一起工作，我告诉同事们，我们都谈论这个，走廊里可能有10位神经治疗师。我们都可以在同一栋楼的同一层办公，我们不会抢对方的客户。我的意思是，对治疗和提升的需求就是这么大。
So yes, I think that we really do, not just lip service to this idea, but we really would be doing right by the community if we did work together much more than we seem to be working together now. Yeah. If we, go ahead, I'm sorry. No, I just agreed with you. Okay.
所以是的，我认为我们确实需要，不仅仅是口头上支持这个想法，如果我们比现在更多地合作，我们真的会对社区做正确的事。是的。如果我们，你说吧，抱歉。不，我只是同意你的观点。好的。
Well, go ahead and agree with me. Well then, it's a fun joke. So if we saw a person's brain map and we were knowledgeable about their history, then you know what a brain map looks like. It's multi-pages, a lot of pictures, a lot of, of I mean just kind of like a map and so on the summary page You'll be looking at five heads from slow brain waves all the way to very very fast brainwaves it's color coded as to how much of each of those firing classes that the brains making and so if a person
好吧，继续同意我吧。好吧，这真是一个有趣的笑话。所以如果我们看到一个人的脑图，并且了解他们的病史，那么你就知道脑图是什么样子的。它有很多页，有很多图片，有很多，我的意思是就像一张地图等等，所以在摘要页面上，你会看到五个头部，从慢脑电波一直到非常非常快的脑电波，它根据大脑产生的每种放电类别的多少进行了颜色编码，所以如果一个人
Was was saying that they were struggling with some concentration vigilance and some just kind of not being able to sustain attention like they once did or that they would like, then that would usually look on the map like the person is a little bit underpowered with how much of what we call beta being generated in certain spots And now Joel all this is I'm speaking very upper level and I know that You you know this but this is very nuanced So but but but in general talking just kind of broad strokes Person would show that they're not generating enough
说他们在集中注意力、警觉性方面遇到困难，或者只是无法像以前那样维持注意力，或者他们希望能够维持，那么这在脑图上通常看起来像是这个人在某些点上产生的所谓“贝塔波”有点动力不足。现在乔尔，我说的这些是非常高层面的，我知道你了解这一点，但这非常微妙，所以，但总的来说，大体上，这个人会表现出他们没有产生足够的
of a wavelength that we call beta that is associated with cognitive output, memory, sequential processing, to some degree mood. So it would be color-coded to where that's a little bit low. So if all things were equal, then to help that individual, we would put implements on the head that give off electromagnetic field frequencies, and probably also add some implements giving off some very, very gentle AC frequencies. So a couple of electrodes. I know that's a scary word for people sometimes,
我们称之为贝塔波的波长，它与认知输出、记忆、顺序处理以及某种程度上的情绪有关。所以它会被颜色编码显示为有点低。因此，如果一切条件相同，为了帮助那个人，我们会把设备放在头上，发出电磁场频率，可能还会增加一些发出非常、非常温和的交流电频率的设备。所以几个电极。我知道这对人们来说有时是一个可怕的词，
but some sensors in some strategic spots, according to the brain map, in our knowledge of neuroanatomy as to what's happening with that person, put the sensors in the spots to get to the regions that we're trying to get to, and with the EMF emitters. And then we simply give those beta frequencies.
但在一些战略位置放置一些传感器，根据脑图，以及我们对神经解剖学的了解，了解那个人身上发生了什么，把传感器放在试图到达的区域，并使用电磁场发射器。然后我们简单地给予那些贝塔频率。
It's more detailed than this, but overall, you're giving those beta frequencies that the brain is having a hard time generating on its own. You give those frequencies, and now in a matter of minutes, now the brain is potentiating more of that frequency. So they leave the office differently than they arrive and that will continue, the brain will keep functioning that way for essentially the rest of the day, the next 12 to 15 hours and then it will begin to fade off. And then with repeated presentations of those frequencies, multiple sessions of those frequencies,
这比这更详细，但总的来说，你给予了大脑自己难以产生的那种贝塔频率。你给予这些频率，现在在几分钟内，大脑就会增强更多的那种频率。所以他们离开办公室时与到达时不同，这种情况会持续下去，大脑基本上会在当天剩下的时间，接下来的12到15小时内保持这种功能，然后它会开始减弱。然后通过重复呈现这些频率，多次疗程的这些频率，
the brain begins, we say the word entrained, it just learns and memorizes those frequencies and begins to function that way for longer before it fades away. And as you're creating the synapses between the tracks that support that activity, you're actually creating pathways or strengthening weak pathways, then that's what makes that change permanent to where eventually they'll no longer need that stimulation. The brain's now doing it on its own. It now has the network that it has created
大脑开始，我们称之为“夹带”，它只是学习并记住了这些频率，并开始以这种方式运行更长时间，然后才消失。当你建立支持该活动的轨道之间的突触时，你实际上是在创建路径或加强薄弱的路径，那么这就是使这种改变永久化的原因，最终他们将不再需要那种刺激。大脑现在正在自己做这件事。它现在拥有了它所创建的网络
through protein synthesis and all of this working together. Now the brain is able to function that way on its own. And then you begin to talk about discontinuing the therapy or move on to the next phase. If the brain needs something else in addition to that, then to move on and go to the next phase. That's what that would look like. Then doing the brain map roughly every 10 sessions to make sure
通过蛋白质合成和所有这些共同作用。现在大脑能够自己以这种方式运作了。然后你开始谈论停止治疗或进入下一个阶段。如果大脑除了那个还需要其他东西，那么就继续前进，进入下一个阶段。这就是它看起来的样子。然后大约每10次疗程进行一次脑图绘制，以确保
you're still doing what the brain precisely needs at that moment. Making changes to the protocol, if you're now done with that phase, now the brain is now showing us that it needs something else, or now there's an inefficiency that we can now see that we couldn't see before because something was covering it up. And this can get really detailed, but in general, that's what it would look like. Well, and they know the map is a map, whereas the neuromodulation is a treatment. And so the same
你仍然在做大脑在那一刻精确需要的事情。如果现在那个阶段已经结束，对方案进行更改，现在大脑向我们展示它需要其他东西，或者现在存在一种我们以前看不到的低效率，因为有什么东西掩盖了它。这可能会变得非常详细，但总的来说，它看起来就是这样。嗯，他们知道地图就是地图，而神经调节是一种治疗。所以同样
thing that the map indicates this kind of cognition is what is hard and what needs to be focused on improving. Neuromod is the only way to do that, but we use a tap read the maps clinically a ton. When I'm like, okay, that makes sense. You have to have a really hard time focusing. Let's try and get you to focus on something pretty granular for a session and see what the protective parts that flare up when
的事情，地图表明这种认知是困难的，需要专注于改善。神经调节是做到这一点的唯一方法，但我们临床上大量使用脑图。当我说，好的，这很有道理。你一定很难集中注意力。让我们试着让你在一次疗程中专注于一些非常细致的事情，看看当你
you are trying to concentrate on something. How do you try and pivot off that and deflect and spin off? For myself, it's like exhaustion. If I sit down and try and write something, I'll just get a headache or I'll immediately get tired. I know that that is a defensive thing that I've worked on in therapy. A lot of the neuromodulation was helped for us. If I could say say one one more thing
试图专注于某事时，哪些保护性部分会爆发出来。你怎么试着从那里转移、偏转和旋转？对我自己来说，就像精疲力竭。如果我坐下来试着写点什么，我就会头痛，或者我立刻就会感到疲倦。我知道这是一种我在治疗中处理过的防御性东西。很多神经调节对我们有帮助。如果我能再说一件事
um, uh, you know parents parents usually so I see a lot of Autism a lot of ADHD a lot of anxiety. Um, I mean we all see these people. Um And so people so so so people come in and they they ask Okay, we want to find out if this If this is a difficulty related to a won't or a can't. And so we're trying to problem solve as to whether the concentration, for example, the concentration issue is just simply poor discipline or if this is a truly, if this is a can't. So the brain map can help us delineate between what's just simply what the brain can do, but the person just lacks discipline because it's not a lot of fun to concentrate versus if it's really having a neurological difficulty concentrating. Case in point for this is anxiety, uh, we see it we see it a lot, um
嗯，你知道父母，父母通常，所以我看到了很多自闭症，很多多动症，很多焦虑。嗯，我的意思是，我们都看到了这些人。所以人们，所以人们进来，他们问，好的，我们想找出这是否是一个与“不愿”或“不能”有关的困难。所以我们正在试图解决问题，比如注意力，例如，注意力问题仅仅是纪律不严，还是这确实是一个“不能”。所以脑图可以帮助我们区分什么是大脑能做到的，但那个人只是缺乏纪律，因为集中注意力并不好玩，还是这真的是一种神经学上的集中注意力困难。这方面的一个例子是焦虑，嗯，我们经常看到它，
That that a person will come in and they'll be really wanting assistance to reduce anxiety And so in the brain map And anxiety can look at different things but two major ways that anxiety can present in a map Is being very heavy in the fast firing speed, what we call high beta. And so having a lot of that very fast activity from certain regions, then you can infer that the person is high arousal, that the person is genuinely they're anxious due to a high arousal level. But anxiety can also present an elevation in the amount of what we call theta, which is a slower waveform.
一个人进来，他们真的想寻求帮助来减轻焦虑，所以在脑图中，焦虑可以表现为不同的东西，但焦虑在脑图中表现出来的两种主要方式是：在快速放电速度上非常重，我们称之为高贝塔波。所以从某些区域有大量那种非常快的活动，那么你可以推断出这个人处于高唤醒状态，这个人确实是因为高唤醒水平而焦虑。但焦虑也可以表现为我们称之为“西塔波”的量增加，这是一种较慢的波形。
So sometimes theta, which is an introspective, like a meditation, it's an internal self-monitoring activity. So when a person is showing us a lot of theta on their maps, you can go, huh, so this person may have a hard time focusing. Like theta can be a slowing, like an ADHD, kind of daydreaming and drifting away. That could be the meaning behind what the theta is showing us or the person can be really screaming with their theta because they're trapped thinking about self they're trapped inward there's their their self-referential type reflection yes yes and they can't get
所以有时西塔波，这是一种内省的，像冥想一样的，是一种内部自我监控活动。所以当一个人在他们的脑图上向我们展示大量西塔波时，你可以说，嗯，所以这个人可能很难集中注意力。就像西塔波可能是一种减速，像多动症，那种白日梦和漂移。这可能是西塔波向我们展示的含义背后的原因，或者那个人可能真的在用他们的西塔波尖叫，因为他们被困在思考自我中，他们被困在内心，有他们的自我参照类型的反思，是的，是的，他们无法
off that merry-go-round of, of just monitoring self, but how they're feeling and, uh, and they can't drop it. They want to just take a brief rest and go and do something else for leisure. But that theta wants to keep them handcuffed to that thought and keep on thinking about how bad you feel. Keep on thinking about difficult things. Um, so that's, that's one example about how a presentation does not look one certain way.
摆脱那种仅仅监控自我的旋转木马，以及他们的感受，嗯，他们无法放下它。他们只想短暂休息一下，去做点别的事情来休闲。但那种西塔波想把他们铐在那个想法上，继续思考你感觉有多糟糕。继续思考困难的事情。嗯，所以这就是一个关于表现形式看起来并不只有一种方式的例子。
You have to do the clinical interview to understand the person and then pair that with the brain data or else you could make a mistake. Yeah. Yeah, and I think every model of therapy kind of has dead ends and that's one of the ones that sometimes the people that are less flexible with a very subjective model or a very somatic model get people stuck in just endlessly thinking about how bad that they feel with kind of no out. And a lot of times you can see what kind of therapies you need, what kind of therapy you don't. A joke with the therapist is like anybody that calls and says they want existential therapy probably doesn't need it. They're probably too much in their head and kind of need to get in their body
你必须进行临床访谈来了解那个人，然后将其与大脑数据配对，否则你可能会犯错。是的。是的，我认为每种治疗模式都有死胡同，这是其中之一，有时那些对非常主观的模式或非常躯体化的模式不够灵活的人，会让人们陷入无休止地思考他们感觉有多糟糕，而没有出路。很多时候你可以看到你需要什么样的治疗，不需要什么样的治疗。和治疗师开个玩笑，就像任何打电话说他们想要存在主义治疗的人可能并不需要它。他们可能太沉浸在自己的头脑中，需要进入他们的身体
You know a lot of people do call and say they want existential therapy But a lot of times we kind of want the opposite I think Uh, or we need the opposite of what we we think we want to get better. Um Because what we said earlier that the brain wants to double down on what it knows how to do well And a lot of times we need to do something that we don't know how to do yet That is well said Well, do you have anything to add I'd love for people just to know about the technology internationally a lot of our listeners is Therapy patients therapists and therapy nerds, you know kind of across the world, but there's also you know, a of local listeners. So if you're in Alabama, this is something that Jay and Diana can do for you. If you're in Texas,
你知道很多人确实打电话说他们想要存在主义治疗，但很多时候我们想要的是相反的，我认为，或者我们需要我们认为我们想要的东西的相反面才能好起来。嗯，因为我们之前说过，大脑想要加倍投入它擅长的事情，而很多时候我们需要做一些我们还不知道怎么做的事情。说得好。好吧，你还有什么要补充的吗？我希望人们了解这项国际技术，我们的很多听众是治疗病人、治疗师和治疗极客，你知道，遍布世界各地，但也有很多本地听众。所以如果你在阿拉巴马州，这是Jay和Diana可以为你做的事情。如果你在德克萨斯州，
it's something that Jay can do for you. And if you're not, there's a lot of people who are doing what they're doing elsewhere that you can form partnerships with and really expand your practice and your ability to help people. So, you know, gettherapybermingham.com is the place to go in Alabama to, you know, hit that QEG brain mapping page. You can watch a video of me getting one done on me. They really wouldn't stay HD on it. Did not know what she was going to see. That really was the real map.
这是Jay可以为你做的事情。如果你不在，有很多在其他地方做他们所做事情的人，你可以与他们建立伙伴关系，真正扩展你的实践和帮助人们的能力。所以，你知道，gettherapybermingham.com是阿拉巴马州要去的地方，你知道，点击那个QEG脑图页面。你可以看一个我做脑图的视频。他们真的不会在上面保持高清。不知道她会看到什么。那确实是真实的地图。
Then there's a lot of information on that page too. Peak Neurosciences website if you're in Texas. Is there anything that you want to add or that you feel like is useful for people that are wanting to learn about these things? You have anything to add, Diana? Yes, we have had lots of feedback from our clients and the main feedback is, okay, so I'm not making it up. You can see it in the map. And I think that
然后那个页面上也有很多信息。如果你在德克萨斯州，Peak Neurosciences网站。你有什么想补充的，或者你觉得对那些想了解这些事情的人有用的吗？你有什么要补充的吗，戴安娜？是的，我们从客户那里得到了很多反馈，主要的反馈是，好的，所以我不是编出来的。你可以在地图上看到它。我认为
it has been very validating for a lot of people just to see the map and see that, you know, it is in my head, but it's not like I'm making it up. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. And I would I would encourage people to Uh find someone who is board certified in neurofeedback This unfortunately, uh is is a treatment modality that people are allowed to do without any special certification in it. Now that's changing, it's not gonna be that way for much longer, but right now you can see a person,
这对很多人来说是非常有验证性的，仅仅是看到地图并看到，你知道，它确实在我的脑子里，但并不是我在编造它。嗯哼。嗯哼。我会鼓励人们寻找一位神经反馈方面的委员会认证人员。不幸的是，这是一种人们可以在没有任何特殊认证的情况下被允许进行的治疗方式。现在这种情况正在改变，不会再持续太久了，但现在你可以看到一个人，
they have to have an independent license to practice, counselor, a psychologist, chiropractor. So they have to be licensed in their field. And I'm sure that people doing this do have training. But I would make sure that you sought consultation from somebody who is what's called BCIA board certified, board certified in neuro therapy. Just to ensure that people have a base level of didactic training with neurofeedback and neuroSTEP. What about the technology? I mean, you don't want to go through everybody and say, good, bad, and in the middle, but just what are things with
他们必须拥有独立的执业执照，咨询师、心理学家、脊椎按摩师。所以他们必须在他们的领域获得许可。我相信做这件事的人确实有培训。但我会确保你寻求的是所谓的BCIA委员会认证，神经治疗委员会认证的人的咨询。只是为了确保人们在神经反馈和神经刺激方面有基础的教学培训。那技术呢？我的意思是，你不想去评价每个人，说好、坏、中等，但关于
the technology that we should look for? I think you guys still are the only providers of neurofield in Alabama that I've ever found, and we've called the other places or looked at them, and they usually tell you what they're using. But some of the older stuff, what I see nationally is there's a lot of people where their site looks good and they talk a good game,
技术，我们应该寻找什么？我想你们仍然是阿拉巴马州我发现的唯一的神经场提供者，我们给其他地方打过电话或看过他们，他们通常会告诉你他们在使用什么。但一些旧的东西，我在全国范围内看到的是，有很多人他们的网站看起来不错，他们谈论得很好，
but you look at what they're actually doing and they're running a brain map, but then they're washing the whole brain with white noise. The plan is the same for everybody and it's just neurofeedback. You're like, well, why would you do an x-ray if you're just going to give everybody the same drug? You know what I mean? The diagnostic maybe makes the patient feel good when you're like, oh, you have anxiety and blah, blah, blah, and they feel heard, but you're not treating that specifically. So why are you even doing them out there? You know, there's a couple of things like that that don't make sense to me that I see.
但你看看他们实际上在做什么，他们在运行脑图，但随后他们用白噪声清洗整个大脑。计划对每个人都是一样的，这只是神经反馈。你会说，好吧，如果你要给每个人同样的药，你为什么要拍X光片？你知道我的意思吗？诊断可能让病人在你像说“哦，你有焦虑症，等等”时感觉良好，他们感到被倾听，但你并没有专门治疗那个。所以你为什么要在那做地图？你知道，有几件事像那样对我来说没有意义，我看到了。
Yeah. And I'm sure practitioners are trying to help people and they're trying their best to do right by people and delivering a therapy modality that they had the most comfort level with that they feel that they're the most effective with. I've got no doubt about that. But there's newer, I'll say more advanced, this sounds like a commercial, I'm not making it sound like that, but doing doing neuro stimulation uh is Much more effective than neurofeedback. Um, it's so not all neuro therapists or uh Private practitioners who who who do neurofeedback in their office?
是的。我相信从业者正在试图帮助人们，他们正在尽最大努力为人们做正确的事，并提供他们最舒适、他们觉得最有效的治疗方式。我对此毫无疑问。但有更新的，我会说更先进的，这听起来像个广告，我不是让它听起来像那样，但做神经刺激比神经反馈有效得多。嗯，所以并不是所有的神经治疗师或在办公室做神经反馈的私人从业者？
um, they're not hurting anybody and they're trying their best to be private practitioners who do neurofeedback in their office. They're not hurting anybody and they're trying their best to be the best that they can be for their clients. But neuro stimulation is being shown. The white papers are coming out. They've been coming out. That's more effective and quicker. It's both.
嗯，他们没有伤害任何人，他们正在尽最大努力成为在办公室做神经反馈的私人从业者。他们没有伤害任何人，他们正在尽最大努力为他们的客户做到最好。但神经刺激正在被证明。白皮书正在出来。它们一直在出来。这更有效、更快。两者兼而有之。
It's more effective and quicker. It's both. It's more effective and quicker. So I would just orient people to seek out practitioners who administer neurostimulation. Sorry, I've got a stuttering disorder. Sometimes it waves at me. It's waiting right now. Neurostimulation, which is that gentle frequency presentation. It's not DNS. We can talk about that. That's something different. Um, but, uh, seek out providers who do neuro stimulation, uh, maybe in
这更有效、更快。两者兼而有之。这更有效、更快。所以我只会引导人们去寻找实施神经刺激的从业者。抱歉，我有口吃障碍。有时它会向我招手。它现在正在等待。神经刺激，也就是那种温和的频率呈现。这不是DNS。我们可以谈谈那个。那是不同的东西。嗯，但是，寻找做神经刺激的提供者，也许
addition to their neurofeedback or, or just in lieu of neurofeedback. Well, um, that sounds great. I really appreciate you guys' time. And if you want to check out Jane or Diana, just go ahead and give us give us a Google and we'll link to everybody's website in the show notes. Thank you all so much. Thank you for having us. Thanks for watching! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
除了他们的神经反馈之外，或者仅仅代替神经反馈。好吧，嗯，这听起来很棒。我真的很感谢你们的时间。如果你想看看Jane或Diana，直接去谷歌搜索一下，我们会在节目说明中链接到每个人的网站。非常感谢你们。谢谢你们邀请我们。感谢观看！本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。